Three. Dus. Oh No,
we're live ladies and gentlemen.
Cheers. Cheers. Cheers. Cheers.
Each other in the eye.
Always look in the eye.
We're drinking because any brown was
not here. Let's be honest. I sorry.
Seven Hashtag chem
trails. Um, so we're here.
This is a fight companion.
If you've never seen a fight or listened
to either one he listened to or heard
or watched a fight companion. We watched
the fights. We kind of talk about him,
but most of the time now
this is fake. Conor McGregor.
That's selling video games.
See this guy, listen to
turn this up. Vaught Jamie.
So you could hear the volume on this. He
looks like Connor's Dad. Listen to this.
Listen to this.
He's too old for this. But what they're
doing here, you're definitely right.
What they're doing is they're
capitalizing on the fucking,
the I slash o for she had our hearts.
Right.
And did you see commerce commercial
with John Lovitz? No. No.
They shot a commercial. Have you
seen it Jamie? And he's like,
I'm one of those horse things going.
How's this? Can Help me win my fight?
Jon Lovitz is like,
what's that?
M a a thing and Kinda like throw
something at him. Yeah. Yeah.
Bad idea.
Right to a movie's good.
19 then we've got a problem. We've got
a problem. Well, he's passed on movies,
which I think is a very, he's a very
wise man. Very wise. Yes, he is.
You ever have a conversation
with him? Oh yeah. Yeah.
You guys had him on your show, right? Yup.
Pat Him on the show the whole time. I've,
I've, I've had some meals
with a dude. Very smart guy.
He's not fucking around. No,
not at all.
And he's been offered and I know from my
age and he's been offered some big time
movies, like not this
bullshit. Most fighters do
like legit stuff and he's like,
Nah man, I can't right now when
you me talking about triple x,
no return of Zen Shit.
Yeah. He, I mean, he's a, that
triple x movie looks so bad.
They should show it to prisoners.
They should.
They should play it over and over again.
Those people in Guantanamo Bay,
they'll give up isis. Don't give
up everybody. Did you see her?
No eggs,
no disease under k Vinci's was a hard
sell for me as it will get in bar fights
with sunglasses on and those fucking
movies. Why does he have glasses on?
Why he's in here? Cause he's awesome.
They did. You see him lip singing.
You like use happy cause the deal came
through and he put on Instagram him lip
singing, but he was doing a Beyonce
song. Hey Bro, stop being silly though.
He's opening himself up.
Not, not silly. Oh No.
You got to have irony when he'd do that.
Must have irony. Didn't have irony.
I got to see it for yourself.
How do you know he didn't have irony?
I'm feeling that I'm
going to say wonderful.
That's not from tripper.
Lax. I don't find them.
I don't mind them in the first one.
I like that jacket on him.
That's a dope jacket.
I want to make a jacket out of a Muskox
have the furry part on the inside
that'll keep you warm. Fuck yeah,
it would probably be too warm.
My dentist almost died of a fraud.
Died
from cold hunting. Muskox you have a
nutty dentist. It's like a crazy big game.
Hunters almost died.
He was hunting muskox and it was the
coldest winter for them up there.
And he almost died. He and his, uh, guide.
Why the fuck isn't he fixing your teeth?
Well, hey does and then, yeah, and
then he goes and shoots animals.
Yeah. These guys get addicted, man.
They get addicted to chase animals.
And muskox is a crazy one because you've
got to go up to the frozen north and
when you're up there, man, there
ain't shit up there. I mean there's a,
there's this kind of Tom Miranda.
This is actually a very good fight.
John Moraga versus Sergio Pettis.
Dangerous fucking fight for pedes.
Morocco who went five rounds with mighty
mouse got onboard maybe four rounds.
You had some pretty bad, he got
beat up, but he rocked mighty mouse.
So the straight left. That's true.
Southpaw fighter Benevidez right? He did.
There's an interesting fight though,
cause Pettis is really young.
It's a big step, big step up. Um,
but anyway, uh, this Guy Tom Miranda,
he's just got this a show, uh, uh,
adventure bow hunter and this motherfucker
travels all over the world hunting
things and he went to, uh, thank you. Was
Antarctica? Wherever the fuck must have,
where do they live? Somewhere near the
Arctic circle. The roof of the world.
It's just, it's just nothing.
I mean, there's nothing,
it's white and flat and snow
for as long as the eyes can see.
And occasionally these animals,
I don't know what the fuck they even eat.
I guess they must like
burrow under the sand. Fine.
Whatever vegetation they eat
that other than shit. Yes.
They eat the grass underneath the, uh,
Tundra. What do they look like? You look,
that's what they look.
There's Tom Miranda right there.
That's him shooting one of those things.
That's this fucking guy.
He's wearing a moonshot.
Literally a moon.
He's got aware that's camel up there
as dressing all white. But he, uh,
oh shit. Shut a polar bear. Polar bear.
Look all the dots around he
killed. He shut up. Polar bear.
Apparently you talked
to the people in Canada,
and polar bears are a lot more common
in Canada than they would have you
believe.
Where they're not common.
Where they're endangered is in areas where
the IFE I shelf is melting Greenland.
Right. But it's, they're
not. It's like grizzly bears.
Grizzly bears used to be in California,
but now they're gone. They died.
The last grizzly bear died in
the 18 hundreds in California,
which is weird because grizzly
bears are state mascot. Correct.
If you look at our state flag,
rather,
the grizzly bears on the state flat
black beer, I'm the state flag. No, no.
That'd be a Grizzly, grizzly
bear. And, um, you can, you know,
you can hunt grizzly bears in Alaska.
There's a lot of them.
So they're extinct here. But
there's a lot of, I'm in Alaska.
That's kind of the same
thing with polar bears.
Like people think that polar bears
are extinct or going extinct.
They're not in Canada.
And my friends in Canada that
live up there that are hunters,
they tell me there's a lot of
polar bears and bear, right? Yeah.
It's a terror, terrifying
bear. Polar bears the most
aggressive. Here's the worst.
They are the shot.
This guy is a different guy.
I shot straight out of the fucking age.
Who's like a star wars animal.
Right. Well, it's got to deal with those
insane winners and he just dropped that.
They supposed to be delicious too.
It's like one giant Ribeye.
A lot of stat. Yeah.
Okay, so Moraga and Pedis.
It's four minutes and 15 seconds. Then
has the princess Leia horns. Yeah,
look at it, man. Well, you can see. Yeah.
If you're watching this fight at home,
four minutes, eight, four minutes,
seven minutes, six, four minutes.
Five more minutes for us to sync it up.
Um, but uh, these guys that go up there,
you know, you're experiencing
30, 50 below zero. Fuck all that.
Can you schedule me that the first
and never, that was never, ever to,
they do an intense, sometimes God
done, they go out there on snowmobiles.
It's the only way to
travel. Yep. No thanks.
Which is also can't deal with that
cold. That's just crazy. I'm a Raga.
I was always, I always thought he was a
south by, I guess he switched it up a bit.
He was going back and forth quite a bit.
Yeah. This is a lot for pedis. Yeah.
He's an experienced guy. He's 10
years old or almost nine years older.
It's been around.
But you know what,
one of the things that happens with those
guys that had been around you always
got to wonder like, have they decided
they can't be champion anymore? You know,
are they still 100% all in living it,
breathing it or have they reached that
point where they've got a few losses
against top flight competition and the
reality of their bills and their life
sets in and you know, you got to
wonder. I think that's more realistic,
especially with a guy like him who knows.
I don't know where his mindset that,
but you know,
he got dominated by Joey Benevidez
and he gets smashed by the champ.
It's kind of like God. Yeah, he had a good
fight with mighty mouse, but my decent,
just too goddamn fast did work. But
he did crack mighty mouse ran. He, he,
he probably caught mighty mouse the
hardest in a championship fight.
He caught him flush. So we were
talking about this before the fight.
I still haven't seen it.
Let's see if Jamie can co we get cracked.
Who's got cut current. Sergio, Landon
and a nice right hand there. Um,
someone landed in Ezekiel choke while
mounted earlier in the card that the
heavyweight first ever a Zeke,
you'll choke in the UFC.
And he did it from the bottom. What
isn't Ezekiel? Ezekiel choke is,
it's mostly done with the gate.
You can do it without the gay,
but this one here all the time.
Yeah.
You grab your sleeve like this here and
then you go like that and wrap it like
across the guy's neck from the
bottom. Look, this is incredible.
He's essentially doing a rear naked
choke almost god from while mounted.
It's a snaky. Oh yeah. Nasty.
He's got so disappointed with him.
Well he's obviously, it's
on Badass. That's what I'm
saying. Now he was mounted,
he was mounted and he caught
that chuck c one more time.
So going to be the most embarrassing
laws to be the heavyweight on top.
I don't know if it's embarrassing man,
because look,
what the fuck do you do when a guy's
got that on you? Good and poke that out
by any means necessary.
I don't think he expected it.
So he thought he was safe because he was
mounted and he just fucking tapped. Wow.
That's amazing. That's a heavy one of the
year. That's a heavier with 50 fights.
Who? His homeboy. What's his, what's
his name? He's a fucking oldest shit.
The Boa constrictors 50 fights.
Lexi Russian feller.
Interesting.
Awkward.
Just submitted another heavy way
from the bottom wall mounted.
I wonder if we let them mountain.
I would like to see the whole fight.
I didn't see the fire. That's like his
go to move. I didn't see that either.
My brother texted me, said hey this
headway just submitted guy from mount.
So he always does that.
No,
I'm saying I wonder if he let him get
him out cause that's like maybe as go to,
I've got that in Nogi from the
mount from an hour's mounting.
So I'm on your on top all the time. Not
all I've, it's rare man. Most against it.
Against a high skilled guides can
be tough. What would the Gooey,
I've got it with a g but would never seen
it without a d to be honest. Oh really?
No. I've got hers done it
to me a couple of times,
but I've never done done it to me.
Wow.
Well they have some long ass arms,
man.
Long skinny arms are so good for those
kinds of moves. I mean it's on her.
I mean that's for sure.
The first Nogi this week you'll choke
in the se even crazier than the guy was
mounted and a heavyweight. Yeah. Crazy.
Oh, cracked. They both
cracked the same time. Damn.
Do pedes looks real good. Yeah,
he does. He looks real good.
Moraga swinging for the fence. Oh, we
tagged him again. Pedis. Tag them again.
Catch him on the forehead. Pettis
was looking slag guy. He really is.
So what do you think of his brother is?
I thought it was brothers fighting or
mayor back. Tice him off. Wait, is that,
is that his brother Anthony Pettis?
Yes. Oh, I didn't know that. Oh Man.
That's the end of the first round.
Not knowing the surgery look really good.
Not In this fight and not in
this car. He's not, but uh,
I saw that on Instagram and make
sure that's true. Might not be true.
Might be like at 55
though. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
He's going back up to 55 that's the
right choice, man. Yeah, I think so too.
But I think he's got to put some mass on.
I think he's got,
you know when you're dealing
with these Eddie Alvarez Hofeld,
those Anjos type guys that are just
mauling him and just staying close to him
like glue. I just physically strong
enough. I think it's a physical thing,
but it's also a technique thing.
Grappling is just not in his wheelhouse
really when he's gotten better.
I'm not saying that it's,
he's not good at it,
but to the level that he Alvarez
and dos Anjos it's tough.
Although he did submit Benson
Henderson, right? Yup, Yup.
He submitted that government guillotine.
Yeah. There's some slick Jujitsu,
but when it comes down like the grind
Charles or transitions and stuff submitted
all too. Yeah, I guess. Slick
Jujitsu. Yeah. Whenever,
whenever he fights a bigger dude who can
grapple typically when he loses. Yeah.
Well these fucking guys, man,
they lose a ton of weight.
They come in big and heavy and strong
and they're better wrestlers then mall
nightmare. Yeah. And he's used to getting
mauled in the gym. You know, he, he's uh,
Ben.
Any screen with Ascar look at that.
He gets cracked and then he
cracks him back. Oh, amazing.
Wow. Pedis looking slick coming
together. He looks amazing.
One 26 small guys fly waits on God.
Flyweight Sun. There you
go. Thanks buddy. Yeah,
it's a tough division to sell right now.
You know what I mean?
Mighty mouse dominate in the division
and they have that ultimate fighter
episode. Tim Elliot wins
the ultimate fighter fights.
Mighty mouse gives them a hell of a fight.
Hardest fight he's ever had.
And then mighty mouse. I
mean, he essentially says,
I can't ever fight this weight
class again. I gave money
mouse a hell of a fight.
But he goes, but he was,
my body was freezing up,
locking up walls inside the occupied.
Yeah. Wow. He's going up to 35.
So that's one more. And of
course a Linacre, uh, was a,
a big guy at 25.
He goes up to 35 and Tj Dillashaw
just fucking ran a train on God.
That was crazy. Ooh, she's yellow junkie.
How good. Teach straight up train.
Now you've got TJ verse Cody.
That's going to be fun. Yeah. Yeah.
That's going to be amazing. That
is a tough fight to call it. Okay,
so here's the fight, right? So the dude's
on top of him and he locks it up. Look,
he's got the arm he's holding on it.
It looks like a troll in a posture.
Here he has it set up sort of
almost in the dude mountain.
And then he slides in under the neck.
Look at this. He bathed in winter, I feel.
Yeah, I feel like he did
too. And look at that.
Look at how he's like locking
him in place. Wow. He's,
he's holding on in the mount while
he's getting tapped. It's crazy.
He's using the guy on top is using
the, the uh, the grape vine. Look at,
look at how he like, this is pretty
slick. It's pretty slowly. This is hard.
Well, you hold onto your arm
the same as a rear naked choke.
It's like a rear naked choke,
but you're doing it in the front of his
neck instead of the face and the face.
So he's grabbing, grabbing his own bicep
there. Get a look at the guy on top.
Look how the guy on top is great. Finding
the legs. There you go. That's like,
it's kind of crazy. Yeah. It's
like he's holding him in position.
He's trying to take,
he set them up and gave a mouse.
You see how he leads his hips to the
way to let them slide in the mouse.
Do that all the time.
Hey,
sliding that veterans shit
to give a heavyweight mount
to choke them out. Crazy.
Crazy. That is fucking crazy. One
more time, Jamie. It's pretty cool.
It's that one more time.
I'd like to know what he's doing
with his hand underneath there. Well,
he's doing like a rear naked choke word.
Karate Chop.
Think of rear naked choke
but were nose to nose. Right.
And he's doing this with his hand.
Okay. You know how I'm old school?
Rear naked choke was, see it syncs,
set up, you know, old school room.
Naked choke like Ken shamrock style.
They used to grab the
back of the head like yes,
they would palm the back of
the head and just squeeze it,
which kind of can work but not on the
best guys. The best guys. You gotta,
you gotta get the karate
chop in the back of the neck.
That's when you get like vicious leverage.
So he's doing a exactly that same move,
but he's doing it on the front of the
neck and the guy on top had no idea what
was going on. Otherwise he would
a hand fight. Yeah man. He's like,
he can a hand fight. The F on the
front, push down on his elbow.
That doesn't even have a
chance to get out of it. Look,
he doesn't even try to get his
hands in between. He's new.
He doesn't know what's going on.
Yeah.
He doesn't know what's going on and all
of a sudden he's getting past amazing.
How's amazing.
It's really get surprised.
Right? Something in the
rare, well think about it.
There's only one ever, uh,
Zeke you'll choke. That's it.
And it's from while the guy was
mounting him, which is crazy.
There's only one ever, um, Omoplata that's
Ben Saunders. There's also on this card.
Correct. Only ever Omoplata in the UFC,
which is crazy because I have to pull off,
but it happens all the time in the
gym, man. It's tough to pull off.
You know what it is man. Guys usually
rollover they position says submission.
Yeah. Cause you chance to finish it.
Especially with a really tough guy. Yeah.
Especially if they'll shoulder mobility.
But you've seen how immune Ari finishes
it, right. That I'm amazed that that,
that hasn't been in the UFC because that
is such a good technique because you
can get that position because a lot of
times guys will give you like that rubber
guard and mission control position.
Then all you have to do is clear
the neck at that foot across.
Then once you have that foot across and
you just start to set up the Omoplata as
the guys defending the Omoplata,
usually they expose their neck because
they're so concentrating on defending the
Omoplata. Have you seen how
Mackenzie dern sets it up yet?
Did you see her last fight? Yes.
Amazing. And she's a diabetes time piece.
What is going on in the world?
Jamie pull up Mackenzie dern submission.
A lot of people were saying it's
like submission of the year.
She's a real elite Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu black belt and she's a mega ton.
Diaz has daughter and she's adored peers
and she sets up this Alma Plata and
then moves from the Alma
Plata to a choke from the bow.
So she has the Omoplata she gets, she
reaches up and grabs the ways she does,
but she rolls and she winds up like
on her back choking the girl from a
Honeywell's unchecked look. It's
beautiful. She's so good. You know it's,
it's so interesting to see like
super high level Jujitsu. Like,
look how she pins down the neck. She goes
with a high guard and she's using the,
it's not like rubber guard style.
She's doing it different and she's
setting up the Omoplata. Okay,
so she avoids that leg. So that's the
big issue as far as defense is right.
You can't let them roll. Right. So she
sits up, she gets her butt out. Right.
And so the girl keeps trying to do it
and she won't let her. So, but now,
once she gets this position, watch
how she rolls. She rolls on her shoes.
So she pulls her on her back. So look,
look at her. Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah.
She sneaks that left arm under the chin.
Beautiful technique band because
she can't defend with that arm.
The arm up there. It looks, she gives
you the butterfly and the left leg too.
So nasty. Crazy. That's so
nasty. That's so beautiful.
It's so high level. So high level.
And it looks, the way she sets it up.
It's so cool too because she
rolls onto her back to like,
you rarely see anyone do this.
Like watch how she does this.
She rolls under her back and pulls her
on top of her. And that girl is like,
what in the fuck is happening?
She's still
holding on the, on the whole key. Bj used
to do it when he would take guys backs.
Bj has had incredible legs.
He would tie up the arms.
So he's up and he's an
octopus. Yes. And so he can uh,
he could defend against the uh,
or he gets stopped the defense with that
leg while she's doing that kind of same
thing.
But she's doing it from an,
I'm a puzzle that we got that
girl's arm is locked the front out.
So off that girl,
you know when zebras get attacked by
lions or just that sheer terror on their
face, like that girl, she
had no idea what was gone.
Her arm is wrapped up tight.
And then on top of that she's using her
butterfly to, to trap the leg. Like, look,
she wraps on left leg over and then she
goes with the butterfly and the left
side. See how she's doing that. God Damn,
that's so much control. So much control.
And English is who gives a fuck.
I am trying to mark it here.
You can talk to her
through one of the maps.
I'm gonna sliding them to
the ends with Portuguese.
Just broken Portuguese ese with us.
There's apps that um, it's like,
I think it's called Google Lens of
you. A world blends. I've used it.
It's really cool when
you're in another country,
you hold it up to a sign and it translates
assigned to English. Really? Yeah. Wow.
That's amazing.
Dude.
When I was in Italy I would just hold
it up to signs and it would translate
everything into English. So cool.
It's incredible. It's incredible.
I mean real time to real time.
No delay. Yeah, it's amazing.
I mean it's a little broken like cause
the translations off the way they use
their pronouns in note with your phone.
Yeah. You just hold your phone up. God,
it's so cool. It's crazy.
Fuck a tour guide. No Man.
And apparently they're getting so close
to having something that sits in your
ear. Like when you go on
tour or if you go somewhere,
something that sits in your ear and then
translates what they're saying to you
in real time in your ear.
So we don't need to learn anything.
I don't need to learn shit.
I thank God.
Look at this in ear device that translate
foreign languages in realtime as
stories. Dough. What does this call Jamie?
That's amazing. And your translator?
There's a lot of them. So
many people. There's a jobs,
people losing jobs.
I don't know how good they work,
but they're readily available.
So it's already,
you can preorder it. So
maybe it's not, sorry.
Sergio looking for the choke Mirages
all over and we're barely pan pedes.
Got a huge contusion on the inside
of his leg. What are dollars?
I'm fucking in crazy.
That was probably worth,
that'd be $200,000 five years ago.
What's that?
Is it 4,000 oh funds.
Oh 4 million raised. Oh,
so it's like a Kickstarter.
Indiegogo flopped out. I'm not.
I want the second generation.
You don't want that first one.
Nobody get you in trouble. Get you in
big trouble. Trouble in South America.
You might talk some shit accidentally
lead you to a whorehouse.
So confused Rog on toughie
figures or rock on top here.
So aggressive
or house email. I don't know. We're
down South American of course.
I'll see you guys. Never been
for God sakes. I hear it. Yeah.
That's legal down there.
If it's legal, it's not.
How about Padis people love to
go to South America to surf. Yes.
Oh look, it's Morocco. Drop it now
for a leg lock holds on. Hold on.
You know what man, this is
changing. Nogi Changing Nogi his
leg locks.
It is a transforming Nogi.
It is all and it's just a matter of
time before these Gary Tone and type
characters. He's Eddie Cummings
start getting into MMA.
Guys help tonight. The massing
health, he's a master with leg. He is,
but he's fighting Lozan and
Joe Lowe's on it is a very,
very good grappler and certainly good
enough to defend and keep that guy off.
I'm so,
it's going to be real interesting to see
whether or not Marcin can get it to the
ground and whether Lozan is
up on all the latest shit.
I hope it goes to the ground. It could
be my relief to those hands. No joke man.
His ground game is super fast too.
He dives on Great Kansas
leg likes changing. No Gate.
Well there's a whole,
there's a whole trans,
a whole a path that took place and one
of the big parts of it was dean lister.
Dean lister was like one of the original
leg lock guys in America and super high
level black belt. You know Abu Dhabi
champion. I mean Dean lister is a beast.
Not a stick. A human being is
sticky. Yes. You know, and he's,
you know, he hasn't had the success
lately that he had when he was younger,
but make no mistake about it.
His knowledge of grappling,
super, super high level.
Well he went down to hens.
Those who the fuck was fighting that he
went down to hand those to help somebody
out. How long ago was, this
was a while ago. A goddamn it,
why don't I know the fucking anyway,
point point being he helps them guys
down at hens o's and showed them some of
his leg lock stuff and uh,
that started with this John,
Donna,
her John Danaher who's essentially
one of the smartest guys in Jujitsu.
It might be another prophet. He's
a fucking Silvant, the savant.
He's got a fucking awesome Instagram post
today I think or maybe yesterday about
using the legs while grappling and how
important it is to learn how to use your
legs and how much more strength you have,
any legs and Durrance
you're having your legs.
And if you get used to using your legs
a lot in grappling how much quicker you
can progress you use
Bj Penn as an example,
is also the same guy that will rock an
under Armour fit shirt with jeans at the
rash guard.
Oh,
John John's always in a rash
card. He said, no matter what,
he's an animal does not give a fuck.
And he has like rules like that he'll give
you as to when you should get married.
And they're basically never, but he goes
over, all the students were like, yeah,
if you're over 50 and she's under 25
and like she's worth millions of dollars
and she makes it so you don't have to
work. And she brings in other women.
She breaks crazy. He's got, he's got a
great sense of humor. He's always calm.
He's always joking. Like, you know,
he's got his phd in
philosophy from [inaudible].
We get started ladies, you know,
I've done it. Her got started. No,
but I was there when John was, you know,
when I was hence us for the year I was,
I'd see John Literally every day.
John was a bouncer and he
was a big fucking lifter dude
once, right? That's right.
Yeah.
And he wanted to learn how to do martial
arts to protect himself because he's at
work. So he starts doing Jujitsu and
goes, oh look, I found my life's work.
Yes. And then he gets super into, it,
becomes a black belt and not just like
one of the most respected black belts,
but starts coaching and teaching people.
Apparently he's got like some
bad joints, man. Like real bad,
like he's got a bad hip and he had
it replaced and he's got a bag.
It's got a bad knee, but he, I think the
need is a genetic defect. There is just,
he's so funny fucking genius guy when it
comes to [inaudible] tied to the Donna,
her death squad,
all those guys that he's got in New
York out of hens owes like Gary, Tony,
like Eddie Commons, all these super
high level leg lock attack guys went,
by the way,
Gary Tobin's having a submission grappling
match against Hector motherfucking
lumbar. What? Yeah, I think
it's flo grappling flow.
Is that what I'm about? See if you could
find that Sony and stuff. I don't know.
I don't know. It might be, I hope it is.
I hope for children it is because that's
an awesome match up, so that's a great,
and he just got done fighting Tacchino
you know he fought who some are.
Paul highrise went to a draw
with him and Paul Harris was
like Jacqueline Lane, one of those
late night commercials on like Fridays.
Look at that. Okay. What is it? Oh
my gosh. Jeff Glover in this too.
What? Who's Jeff Glover having an
event with submission underground. Oh,
submission. Underground. Okay. Is this
chill Sundance thing? I feel like it.
It feels like it is too. Who's
that giant guy? That's Hector.
Hector lumbar. I was going to say,
yeah, the pegs are lumbar. Does.
Is he suspended for a while?
Yeah, Dude. He was in some sweats.
I thought they were spray
painted on when I saw him.
Remember that he had the last time.
Sergio Pettis by decision. Best ads I've
ever seen. She scroll up a little there.
Why? What does this Dylan, Dennis
clovers. Chaz mess right here.
What's going on here? Jon Jones. Jon
Jones is taking on Dylan. Dennis.
It's a fan poster,
so I don't know Jesus.
That's boss logic that artists
and I'd be the best in the world.
You've seen his posters he made, he's the
one it, there's all those crazy posters.
Dope, dope posters. Jacobs. Is he the one
that did Conor McGregor in an MMA glove?
Punching Floyd and the mount?
Correct.
Here's The New York one with all
the dope stuff. Let me tell you,
here's where I'm kind of a kegger can win.
Here's where Conor McGregor
can win MMA gloves.
Let's have a boxing match with MSA group.
I don't think you need to do that if
Floyd's ha boys had some serious problems
in the past with his hands.
Correct.
And he uses those big ass
pillow gloves because of it.
And he's been known to not really sit
down and he's punching just picks guys
apart. He no doubt about it.
Floyd is a masterful boxer,
but that's a big transition for
him to fighting with small gloves.
He's never going to go big
is the transition is for
Connor to fight with bigger
gloves. Right. They're
going to do boxing. But I,
I honestly think with how common
moves, it's, don't get me wrong.
Floyd's one of the best of all time,
if not the best,
but it's a lot for him to adapt to.
Connor's big. He, it's fucking hard.
He can go both ways. We'll
see. Yeah, we'll see.
I want to see what all of the
worst he's going to happen. Oh,
is he the one who did the fucking Joey
Diaz and me fucking caliber beam has got
them Joe Chili with his gum for
bringing him back.
Oh, he's fine. Out of his mouth. Uh,
he's an animal kind of really fight.
That's not going to happen. That fight.
Hey Dude, it's a lot of fucking money.
Here's the deal.
14 with this landscape of view made
300,000 by Dana had a real good point.
He goes, Connor's last two paper
views where 1.3 million, 1.5 million,
he goes Floyd's was 300,000 and it's a
great point and Floyd's asking for 500
million or 400 million, rather. He goes,
you're out of your fucking mind. He goes,
here's a real deal.
I'll give you 25 million.
I'll give Connor 25 billion and then
we'll talk about pay per view after you've
written them a thousand from Reebok's
4,000 it's a not a championship fight,
but it's a main event. But Oh
look at this. Boom. Hey Be,
this is why it's getting serious.
Cause Dana addresses it made
an offer on national TV.
Floyd was on showtime
last night and they go,
is there any boxer that could bring
you out of retirement? He goes, nope.
The only fight that would get me out of
retirement is Conor Mcgregor's the only
fight I want. He knows there's
so much money in that fight.
Conor McGregor is a God damn
fucking happened. But see,
the thing is that's a fight that would
transcend into the total casual person
the same way the Ronda Rousey fight to do,
but this soul dump on my concrete million.
This might be like 3 million because it
might be like such a freak show. Three,
four mil?
I think so.
What's that most never be Andrew,
what would you say?
Like the biggest paper you fight ever?
Like what was the number?
Number one of all time. How awesome
is that the biggest of all time,
isn't it? We get red bull before we
look at the numbers. Let's guess.
I'm going to say 2.5 is that
the biggest helper? I'm say
I'm saying almost three two point it
is for that fight. It is for Pacquiao.
Mayweather. It's you're, you're off
on the numbers. What's the number?
I think it's five right? 4.6 mil. Oh,
that's what I'm saying. Common them,
but damn,
how much might it may where mother
making that fight revenue of 400 million.
Oh my Jesus. So he probably made at
least a hundred plus mom that didn't,
they say made 150 160 million and pack
out made like 80 or a hundred but him and
Connor, you're getting,
even if you hate Connor,
you're still getting all those
MMA fans cause he represents us.
Even if you hate Floyd again,
all those boxes and fans,
even if you hate Floyd and then
the two worlds just go good.
Do you think that he can, that they can
make it up to that level that you think,
wow,
I want to know why.
I want to know why Conor or
how Connor isn't concerned.
He'll get knocked out in the first round.
Nothing to lose.
He won't get knocked out
in the first round. No,
you won't get knocked down the first time.
It doesn't work that way.
As it bought you mean you,
you can protect yourself against even
somebody that could cause very high level
and quick and,
and also Mayweather doesn't hit that hard.
Con is a lot bigger,
right?
Connor moves different than
a lot of boxers do because
he's so used to leg kicks.
He's still used to take downs and he has
a different stance. That alone will be,
we'll take a little bit of time
for me where the, to adjust to,
but may where there has the ability to
be in the right place at the right time
always.
And so deceptive.
It's so deceptive because it doesn't
look like he's doing anything special.
But if you watch the way he's moving,
he's never had a position
and he's always popping.
You went to that jab and he still,
even at 37 38 39 or might
be 40 lightning fast.
Especially lately though, he doesn't
take advantage of getting out of the way.
He's kind of,
he's winning rounds with the Jab.
They dicon and dodging get out of
the way. Um, I just don't got it.
I think for comma though,
man, it's a win win for you.
Imagine if Connor lands the left hand.
I'm saying it ain't gonna Happen,
man.
Listen, Connor fought. I mean, rather,
I'm Floyd fought Ricardo, my Oregon.
Yeah and no, not ricotta. My [inaudible]
you're thinking of Madonna, Madonna.
Mark was my Donna, right. And my Donna
connected at the end of one of the rounds.
He connected with a big fucking right man.
And they had him,
had him sit down for a second.
Yeah. Did he hit? He's a marsh.
Excuse me. He felt like he still, he's
really hot on one shoulder. You know,
there's really no, no, no.
There's a really only once,
but it was the first fight.
The second fight, Floyd boxes,
Jane. And we'll see it here. See?
And my Donna is murderous puncher just,
and he would throw those crazy chocolate,
Dell style overhand rights.
So he's all over Floyd here. And at
the end was one of the rounds. Amazing.
But listen, this guy is way smaller
than Conor. Let's think of this.
We're talking about a guy here
that's fighting one 47 one 54 Connor,
although he's made it down to one 45 he's
physically much larger than this guy.
Connor was walking around.
Am I love that you guys aren't gonna.
He won't put a glove on him and, and
he will not hit him. And I think floor,
it's going to do whatever you want.
You want to bet every lance one?
Sean, you pay none of them
off. It's very strange, Connor.
He always loses to say Conor McGregor
is, he won't stand a shot. Now,
can you pour me some one?
Not at night.
He's starting something that
Atlanta clean. I went to me and Joe.
No pouring some more. Well, what I do
know is that great fighters have the,
haven't done it, haven't we? A, I mean, I
know that he may have no doubt. No doubt.
He Pat cow look clumsy. I know that.
So can have one arm. I know that. Yeah,
let's look at this. He's done
it to everybody. Oh, see my dot.
I clipped him there with a left
or right uppercut rather. But,
but at the end of it, one of them,
oh dude, it's beautiful box that box.
Hey man,
you don't get to be 49 in [inaudible]
without being fucking sensation now.
Just don't, he's the best defensive boxer
of all time. Right? Yeah, I would say.
I would say so. I mean, you know,
pronounced when I was her boss,
Pernell Whitaker lost
later on in his career.
He wasn't able to sustain it as
long as Mayweather has. So what may,
where there's been able to do is sustain
it better than anybody and also keep
improving.
Can mean like when he fought Canelo he,
a lot of people thought Canelo was
going to give him a hard time and young
Canelo he's too big for him. Fuck
Canelo up. Okay, look at this.
They're having the ultimate fighter.
Haven't Cody and DJ and Tj to coach each
other on the ultimate fighter or the
coach that's going to be amazed how much
shit talking is gone and it's going to
be team Alpha male versus TJ through the
psychological damage he could take from
then and counter. I guess Cody has a
tape of him knocking out Tj and practice.
The other is he keeps saying he wouldn't
be saying it unless it was real.
I definitely has it.
Not that that really matters
cause it's practicing and it does.
I mean it's kind of does the day.
Yeah.
I mean listen man,
I'm,
I'm a huge Floyd Mayweather fan of him
like skill wise as a boxer and I think
that he made it through prize fighting
better than anybody ever and that's right.
And he takes top ranked fighters.
I mean the best in the world
who are boxers and does
anything he wants and never
seen anything like it. Gentleman, he's,
he hasn't fun. Two years and he's 40 now.
He's food shop. I don't
care. I don't care.
Well both right. You're both right. You're
both right. You know, I mean that's what,
what makes it so intriguing. He is 40
look, if he was in his prime and a,
it's not a conversation, it's not
really a conversation and you know,
Connor would most likely get boxed
up. It's just a different thing, man.
The what may, where they can do with
his movement like right there. Oh,
look at that pop up.
I mean it's just a difference in language,
but you know what man?
Look what Joe Smith Junior did to Bernard
Hopkins and Bernard Hopkins was like
the untouchable man forever. Now granted
you're dealing with 11 years old.
He's 51 52 father time.
Like Brendan was saying five times.
It's nice to just go hit this,
tap you on the shoulder and just go.
It's time now when you get knocked out.
Undefeated five time is a motherfucker
and he just waits for now.
I think within our lifetime we're gonna
see father time start to take some else.
Technology takes out.
Father, time to thank Doug.
I think what's going to happen is do
you know that there's a startup now that
will fill your body with the blood of
young people like a Goddamn vampire? What?
Give me some of that.
New Research has shown that if you take
old blood from mice and put it in young
mice, they slow down and get
tired and they get sicker.
But if you take young blood from
young mice and put it in old mice,
they literally go back in time. They
reversed. They get cost through.
They have more energy, more better stone
in their bodies. Not just that too.
Not just that like,
yeah,
the age of the blood itself
changes up the mold ass cell.
Hey Bro,
Jamie,
eighty thousand eighty thousand eighty
thousand bucks, they start them.
Cancel your veins with the blood of
young people. Jamie, book an appointment.
The dude's going in. No, we could
just put a post on Instagram.
We get some young broths in La and just
just drain them a hundred bucks for
their blood.
You want a guys blood?
Why did you say that? Doesn't matter.
Like you wouldn't make it the blood.
Seriously though.
Look like sugar hood Bro.
[inaudible] checking blood.
Let's see. Think about that.
They check your blood and they find all
these different things in your blood,
right? They could find steroids in your
blood. They find drugs in your blood.
They also find like what your testosterone
levels are and all sorts of different
hormone levels.
Well,
if that's the case then that means the
blood must vary in its potency and very,
and it's what you would do is you hire
someone to live a monastic life of
nothing but grass fed Muskox Broccoli
and Rockley and fucking asparagus and
shit. You feed this guy like all
the best supplements and get,
get him like super like kid is hormones
just perfect. And Jen, James Brown's no,
you drain them. You take his blood,
you're pumping in to you, you pay him,
you pay him to give up a
gallon of that blood. Yeah.
How much blood is a person keep
on them at any given time, right.
Is that what it is?
Cause you can only donate what,
two or three before you
get all lightheaded.
Have freaking Oj and Shannon
or two maybe one. One.
So if these people are
giving up their blood,
I mean are you getting the blood from
like one guy and then another guy is a
fucking don't gamble all day.
Fake Conor McGregor guy again in this app.
God Damn.
Selling video games for the haircut
against, with a Mohawk. Hey,
this has to be an la or fucking or
it's like in some dark part of Germany,
San Fran. It's a Monterey.
Oh, the start up there.
The first week of fucking shady
book it doctors we're doing,
we're doing cobb's. Hold on. Say that
again. Doctor used to be an Olympic rower.
Yeah. The girl that's running up to
trial, that doesn't mean it a trial.
Do they have any results so far? Have they
done it? Young Plasma. Clinical Child.
They're going to post results as they get,
I don't want to be a Guinea pig. Yeah,
I need some legit shit.
We're doing that. Well,
I'm going to do that and then have that
translate in my ear like an asshole.
Jeez. I would normally say there's gotta
be, don't you in the microphone, Brian?
Jesus fucking Christ.
I would normally say that there's
probably got to be something to it,
but on the heels of that [inaudible]
thing, do you know about Toronto's?
You don't know about that.
Oh my God.
The says is one of the most fascinating
technology stories of the last year.
Toronto's was this huge startup that was,
they were working with Walgreens and
they had these contracts I think with,
I want to say with Costco too, I don't
know who it was, but there was this woman,
she was the, the the biggest
self made billionaire ever.
She was worth at one point in time,
some like $30 billion or
something fucking crazy.
She was the female Steve Jobs and she
would dress like Steve jobs down to the
turtleneck sweater.
The whole deal shit worse than that.
It was all fraud.
Her company was bullshit.
The results were like 65% accurate
and they were trying to pass
it off as being like in the high nineties
they hid results is a blood test.
All they would have to do is
take a prick of your blood.
They take a prick of your blood and then
with that blood they can test you for a
variety of different diseases.
So people were making critical
health decisions based on this,
this blood test that they had,
proof wasn't working correctly.
So one of the people
that worked at Serrano's,
Toronto's rather became a whistle blower.
She went from being worth billions
of dollars to being worth zero.
And now there's like no,
because,
because the government stopped
them from doing these tests.
She's getting suits or the ass for
sure she has money in the bank.
But that's and go well there's no
money anymore. There's no money.
Like she shouldn't have personal money,
doesn't have stock.
Cause he understands she's worth knew.
It was stalled. God. Not only that,
like hundreds of millions of dollars
in loss. I got a good bullshit.
Let me just explain what's happening.
So what happened was everybody bought
this package of who this person was,
this female Steve jobs and they wanted
to buy into, it's so hard, you know,
and it became a marketing thing. She was
wearing black turtlenecks, man. God Damn,
she was literally doing the Steve
Jobs. Look, I will kick the,
he said she a white new balances.
Here's where it all came down to.
It all came down to one really fucking
clunky sentence that she said when she
was trying to explain what,
what went wrong.
See if you pull up the
wired magazine article.
She said something and
what she said was like,
they explained like how it
works and she goes, well,
it's a chemistry that takes place and
like use like incorrect terminology.
And so a writer started digging in.
I realized she didn't know
what she was talking about.
I saw a speech that she gave at
this women's conference thing,
like in this women's empowerment thing.
And when I was watching her talking like,
God,
her thoughts are so cluttered.
It's like she didn't know she was going
to give a speech and she's given this
speech. By the way, this is a fight
as a good fight for two reasons. One,
because Ben Saunders is
fucking wicked on the ground,
especially off of his back and to cause
court McGee has incredible stamina.
I mean incredible. He works out at,
um, yeah. And he's at the pit elevated,
which is up there in Utah,
high elevation.
And the fucking guy is just
relentless with his cardio.
It's like either he's been, it's been,
it's taken a little time off. So Ben,
Ben has had more problems with his stamina
and hope he's corrected that because
I think Ben's nasty to the potty.
He is.
He's very nasty with knees and
he's super good off of his back.
Like one of the best guys off
of his pieces. Long too, man.
He's got those mountains. You see the
um, the statement Jamie, exact statement.
There's an order. First of all,
I came out of the huge ones,
70 hours started at all the whole problem
and then they followed that article.
Oh. If you buy anything from a
lady dressed as a fake Steve jobs,
you're flucht already. You can
go would walk in like, Oh shit.
She's dressed like Steve jobs
to see what's the headline?
Pull up the headline of this article so
I could see if that's the right one. No,
go to the top. Go to the top.
Everything. No, that's not it.
Let's find during, get her blood. No,
her blood filled with debt
fucked. Yeah, she's fun activity.
Hey, think about that phone call when
they called her that she was, they,
it's all out Wall Street Journal did an
article about it exposing it and then
Vanity Fair did an article exposing.
Do you get your news from bro?
That's what she should've said.
Fake News Shit. Hold up. Hung Up.
I already bravo. You see Trump said
that to CNN? He wouldn't answer.
CNA said you're fake news in front of
them in front of him. It's like no,
no answering fake news so bad for CNN.
N You know what?
In this case he's right. They, they
talked about unsubstantiated reports.
I mean they basically were
spreading propaganda for
whoever the fuck invented it.
Whether it's a troll or
whether it's a relation. Yeah,
not good. Not Good. You know,
and try to a really good point.
I kind of liked that. He had a
really good point too. He's like,
everybody knows I'm a Germaphobe.
He goes,
I'm not hiring people to
pee on me or pee on anybody.
Like without fuck are you talking
about? Yeah, that was ridiculous. Well,
apparently the golden shower pex ya that
ex British operative wasn't he hired by
uh,
I think certain democratic super pacs or
somebody like that to discredit Trump.
I mean it's basically, and he came
up with a golden shower parties.
So uncreative bought that shit.
Did you? I did. I was like, Damn,
he likes to party. Sondra is looking
good on the outside, man. Look, we'll do,
I gave it to Rogan. I'm not, I'm
not eating all the podcasts going.
I'm a professional God,
you are a professional.
You're said to some of the C's
you ever tried to work, Bro.
It's gotta be some of the
best cheese, right? Is it raw
milk? Cheese? Sure is. Wow.
You are an artisan.
A cow.
Cow Milk as well as I tolerate goat
milk court has had some serious fucking
injuries, man. It's some battles. Didn't
you have like a serious hand injury?
He had something like two
years off. Yeah. I want,
I want to say it as a hand injury.
Ben Saunders got cut from the UFC.
This his first fight back,
Huh? No, no, no, no, no. He
said more than one fight back,
I believe.
No,
his last fight was in some weird
location unless he went back to yelling.
I'm pretty sure. Why can you confirm
that gym? I'm pretty sure they know what.
I think you're right. He's, this is
his third run with the UFC then. Wow.
He's looking good man and courts cut
cords caught over that left. I see.
But here's the thing, what's
manner? No fight night.
Fight night at the island is what
it was called. I'm sorry. Yeah,
UFC denim to the earlier
last year we had a fight.
UFC fight night 81 January,
2016 and then September he fought fight
night at the island in Wisconsin though.
Yes. Volkman oh, so that would be
go Volkman. Yeah. Jacob Volkmann.
That's outside the UFC. This soda. Yeah.
There's no UFC Highland in Minnesota.
Volkman is a, he's a guy from Minnesota.
He's a chiropractor. Yeah. Good grappler,
man. Real good grappler. He was
like winning fights too. Yeah.
He was one of the guys that called that
Obama after he had been visited by the
secret service call that Obama because
he fucking Obamacare basically killed his
business. Damn. Really?
A lot of small doctor's small practices
apparently suffered from Obamacare.
Have you talked to Volkman about
it? He's very, very vocal about it.
Very upset vocals. He can be. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't, you know what man,
there's not enough shit and you
don't have time rather in the world.
Pay attention to everything.
And um,
when you paying attention to
things that like Obamacare,
if you want to really go through how
it affects all these doctors, you'll,
you'll just probably go crazy and start
feeling sad for all these people that
got fucked over. Look up how
long, how big the bill was.
The initial booking was 2,400 pages.
100 pages. Who's gonna read that?
Nobody. Nobody. Right. Isn't that part
of the problem? I think two people,
two journalists read it and they broke
it down and I tried to read that he got
that Gig. Not so fun. No,
definitely not like doing a podcast who
they probably didn't get paid much. Yeah,
they probably got on
the secret FBI list too.
They probably didn't smoke weed and drink
with their friends. How they did it,
they read the whole thing,
broke it down.
I read that and I read it again and
I still didn't really understand it.
You read their summary. I
read the, how long was their
summary? It was long enough.
No it was, it was long. It was long
enough for me to be terribly bored.
So essentially what,
what is like the main beef is that it
makes employers spend more money on
insurance for their employees because
you can opt out, like you can get people.
Um, I know that I've talked to
business owners about like, so,
so you, you can give them an option, I
guess you can say. You can. Um, it's so,
in other words,
if you're a full time employee,
I have to pay all of your
insurance. Okay. So what,
what one of the side effects
is that companies will say,
well if if it,
if it means I have to hire you for a 40
if 40 hours a week or 30 hours a week is
full time,
I'm going to hire you for 18 hours a week
and hire somebody else for nine hours
a week. So both of you guys
have to work part time.
So what does that do to the
bus boy or guys like that?
They really need that full time work.
Right now they can only work part time
because company can't afford to hire him
full time cause they need to
have some kind of a mandate.
Either he's got to pay a $2,000 something
fine and not paying his healthcare or
he's got to pay for his healthcare.
So there are certain mandated
things and the problem,
I don't know enough about it and I
don't want it. I think it has that.
That's right though be cause I know
people who were affected by the, yeah.
And I know people who need it and there
and there are about 20 million people
that are on it now or something crazy.
Uh, and, and they benefit from it. So,
you know, it's a, it's, it's a tough
issue, but so who's benefiting from it?
The people that drafted it,
we're probably not very business savvy.
They were probably bureaucrats
and not necessarily small,
but they didn't realize they were going
to take advantage of some of the rules.
Did some old figured out a loophole.
So who does benefit from it?
People who can't afford healthcare,
people who get a condition for example.
And then the, the insurance
company drops them. You know,
there are a lot of people
that had health care,
they get a very serious illness and
they get dropped and then then they say,
if you really want healthcare,
now try getting healthcare when you've
got a life threatening disease. So,
so it does help a lot of people.
The problem is once again,
who pays for it and um,
oh Ooh,
how do you get doctors to
do it? And there's all kinds
of things. But then again,
you know, the, what do you think is
the solution as a civilized society?
Do you think that everybody should
have healthcare? Personally? I do.
I get more that way as we get older.
However,
I also think one of the culprits is
a lack of competition amongst states.
And the reason for that
is this. So you, you know,
you're not really able to shop for
insurance across state lines. Why?
Because insurance companies basically
have their territory that they all agree
not to encroach upon. Okay. So
that's, that's another part.
It's kind of just agree to it. Yeah.
They've taken on hold and go, right,
this is my garbage route.
That's your garbage route.
Don't mess with my business.
I won't mess with Your Business. Well,
we need to do is have competition.
One of the ideas is to have competition
among all the insurance companies and to
the lowest bidder goes the spoils.
You know?
So now if I can't get insurance in
California, maybe somebody in Hawaii,
maybe somebody in Tennessee is
offering insurance for less.
Say this fight a, you were missing a
real good fight right here in the UK.
Don't they get free health
insurance? They did. It hurt.
If something goes wrong,
they have to wait like for
fucking ever up the innovation,
the innovation in healthcare.
So it'll be new drugs and all that.
It was here in this country. It's
the same issue with Canada. You know,
some people will tell you it's awesome,
they have free healthcare,
but I've had friends that have had
surgery up there by subpar doctors and
they've had to go in second and third
time to fix things. Or they have to wait.
You have nine months before they
get their automatic a long time.
So a lot of them that have money wind
up coming to America to get surgery from
American surgeons. But I don't know. It
also the innovation in medical technology,
most of it happens in this country,
and the theory is because there's
more profit to be made. Yeah.
Well that's where innovation
gives, gives birth. Yes. I mean,
they have to have incentive in order
to spend money in order to come up with
things like this. Whoa, this is a good
fucking fight, man. Real veterans.
I'm amazed at how good she Saunders is.
Looking on the outside like able to
slide in and out using his reach.
I'm more impressed with court has just
making a dog fight every fight he fights
in his dog fights for guy's a beast.
Didn't do any like die from meth or
some shit and the came back from some
drawing or something like this too.
I think he's a,
he's been to to the other side.
He called Matt Brown.
Him and Matt Brown both have that similar
quality. I spoke to him for a while,
one time and he's such a such a smart,
he's such a sweet guy
dude to struck me as very
intelligent and yeah,
when he gets out of this he's going to
do well for himself in life with whatever
he chooses to do.
I hope he doesn't wait too long to do that
and Ben Saunders is a really nice guy.
We had dinner with him that time.
Really good guy on the companion and
Eddie's there with them right now.
That's why Eddie's not here. Oh,
he's right there in this corner.
That's Eddie by below him. He's well
remember tower seven chem trails.
Remember, tell him about
pizza gate right now. He, um,
he's worked with Ben
Extensively, especially on
its guard with Ben's gardens.
Wicked bends,
the only guy to ever get an omen plot
to in the UFC and his guard is fucking
super high level and he's also got the
perfect build for it cause he's so long
and tall and a,
he spends a lot of time with eddy.
I wonder if seventies too much of a
cup from word of diminishing returns.
He's so fucking no, no, he's okay.
He's okay at 70. You know when we, um,
we joke around but Eddie,
but Eddie is my boy and he's like,
we fucking legitimately one of the very
best Jujitsu instructors on the planet.
He's amazing at anyone gets
that twisted, do they? Well,
they do sometimes because they hear the
conspiracy theory talk and they just
sort of dismiss everything. That's
what people love to do that, you know,
like Eddie loves conspiracies.
That's his shit, you know.
But that's what he's into. His
jujitsu. Jujitsu is top notch,
top notch.
Who the best professors in the world is.
Gyms all over is super successful guy.
What's his innovation too? Was
this a hot look? Japanese girl doe.
Was this commercial always
lead? She's leaving. I, oh,
she's on a black guy's house.
Hey. Oh, Marvin Eastman's
waiting on the other side.
You went old school. Barban he, Paul
Marvin Easton was a tank. He really was.
Maybe Bobby Lashley is
accident right there. My God.
Speaking of tanks, God, he's
Bobby Lashley is ridiculous.
He's just huge. Yeah. You know
who's a ridiculous is fighting soon.
It's Francis and go. No, they
find her lost. You Ready? Yes.
First big test. Where is he fighting
our loft game? Is that Brooke Congo?
That's where the last bottle of malaria
medication in the middle of the Congo.
It's definitely like Congo and it's not
Brooklyn cause that'd be a great fucking
card. Where is that? Uh, put them on
there. They should put them on there,
but I think they're headlining the card.
It's then it's fine.
I think it's a fight.
It's actually in boats in Denver.
How would they put heavyweights in Denver?
You know Joe Silva's gun?
Cause after Mark Hunt flat, Ben Rothwell
I asked for a fight in Denver goes,
we will never let heavyweight fight in
Denver again. Oh guys, guys can't tell.
What do you see something
Rothwell Mark Hunt. Yeah. Ooh.
Too exhausted they gas meanwhile than
they have fucking cane versus we're doom
in Mexico City, which is 2000 feet
above fucking Denver. Seattle.
Think that's our boy Joe Silva doing that.
He knows better what? Mexico City. Yes.
Our new, the new guys like Dan, they'll
figure it out. No, but Mexico City was,
well Joel silver was there.
Damn Sam. Alvin. I know,
but he doesn't make the title
fights. Oh really? What I'm saying?
It's crazy shit. Nate.
Sam. So this is funny.
Nate was Sam's on the ultimate fighter
like they were training partners in this
coach. You know guys sleep on Nate.
You know, which is interesting.
Like CB Dalloway went chasing after Nate,
like Nate's done and Nate uncorked
one on him and knocked him out cold.
I mean he's on the back nine for sure.
For sure.
We're walking them up to that then,
but you can't fuck around with names.
The grade, it's still a powerhouse.
It's still a flowers. Last thing to go.
Last thing to go fight. He's a super
vet. He's been fighting since he was 17,
17 years old.
So crazy.
I was just with Eve Edwards who started
fighting when he was 17 he was at a show,
right? Yeah. Eve is remarkably
well composed. He's so smart.
He's doing that stance now.
Stunts for movies.
That's a dangerous gig per flight.
Yeah.
There's someone died on a Steven Seagal
movie dude stunt. So he needs to know.
No stuck being a stunt man.
Super dangerous because Angela Karen
bands on the show that you can do TV and
you're like, you run into sugar glass and
stuff. Then some of it's cushy, like uh,
the goal versus doesn't have
a lot of big stones. You know,
you have stunt guys on your shot.
Yeah.
Cause the beautiful blackhalls
for wrestling, you know,
all that kind of Schema.
What's going on with your show? Are
you doing a pilot? Are you doing,
you're doing a spin off from the
Goldberg. You want to spin off, uh,
starting in March. I think that's
beautiful. Man. Gets excited about that.
I am excited about it and do table
reads, all that jazz, all that stuff.
It's like how he is. He's just
the best. Let me come on and play.
You're retarded brother. I
love it. I want to do. They do.
They'd have you on dude. Come on man.
You would do it Joe. Yeah, I played it.
He played my brother and he's
radio. I own one. I had a blast.
Him and Nick Depalo and
Epstein from welcome back,
Kotter. They were my brothers.
They all beat the fuck out of me.
Threw me through a plate glass window.
I had to throw myself through one of
those. Um, sugar glass windows. Yeah.
It's freaky man. Really? He's, it looks
like a real way. Scared a little bit.
I was a little nervous. Yeah. You
had such a great time on that show.
It's so much fun. Yeah. We was just Dave,
mostly Dave Foley, who's Dave and
Steven Rude. If I see him and candy.
I've seen candy since, and you know, it's
always great when I run into him. Damn.
Look at all the Phil Hartman and
that's [inaudible] me head on.
You there, cal. And he threw me
through a window or didn't. Nick,
why don't you guys talk to her window
was so much fun. You miss acting at all.
Joe knew nothing about it.
Nope, not at all. Not a thing.
It's takes too much time. I'm
not into doing it. It's a you.
It do it with the actors,
which just never, never.
The best thing to do the actors on your
show is so good. They were great. More.
I even wrote part,
Ben's harness went for that leg,
but he didn't quite get to it quick.
Super Dangerous for court,
even though there's not much time left.
And I feel like he's winning the fight.
I wouldn't mess with it.
I don't know about that.
I think Ben is when the standup,
but he's on top right here. So
let's see. Hello, Casey. Here it is.
Here's the wrap up. Here's the wrap
up. Look at this. Let's see. Oh Wow.
Court shook it off quick. Ben.
Uh, went for the transition.
He went for the transition to change the
name chop and a little wine in there.
Hey, how the honey, the honey man
Trump little humming lamb. Cha.
I wonder who winning this fight since
we weren't really paying. Totally. Yeah.
Court winning. Good ground and pound
here. See, Ben had that position,
man for a very sharp. Okay,
now he's wrapping it up again.
Let's see what he can do,
but it's not, it's not high
enough. Okay, now it's better.
Oh my gosh. What is that
called? A dead orchard.
Both arms trap long legs.
Both arms trapped inside the triangle.
This is named after Nathan Orchard.
This is called the dead org charts,
but the problem is, well,
can he submit from here?
Because a lot of times like he's had guys
stuck in here. Like Kenny Rogers said,
no god, Kenny Roberts, he had him
stuck in here but he couldn't fit them.
Excuse me. You going to be
tough to finish court McGee out.
It's not going to finish them now.
No, it's not. He's on the foot.
He's on the toes on the back of the calf.
You really want to get deep in on the
ankle on this and even so it's just,
it's not there for him. He didn't
have much time to work here. He's now,
it's totally gone.
You can do damage there with elbows,
but you don't manage the court. Drop
some elbows on him. Court just cut him.
Oh Man. Yeah. Courts on top of him
and he's tired now too. You know,
I think he's going to try to switch
to a leg. He's in half guard here.
He's going to try it.
So courtships drop that elbow on him.
He's kind of tried to go,
oh no,
just going to try to go to the under
hook on that left leg and slide under.
But in the meantime he's taken some
shots which trying to Darcy come up.
He is super long. It's easier to get
when they're long. Does that make sense?
So they're really good at
them, but they're also easier
to get caught. Yup. Yup.
Totally right. Damn. And doing work. Yeah.
Big Finish to the fight for court court.
The such a warrior man.
Tough. Every fights just, it's
never easy for him. Is it?
It's just a scrap. Yeah, that's what
he likes. Yeah. Interesting man.
Very interesting.
I mean he looks like an Islamic cleric.
I wish we were paying more attention
to in the 30 seconds I saw.
I'd probably give it to court
with aggression and then
the take down at the end
cause I think like Ben was winning
on the outside earlier in the fight.
Interesting. But that round, that
last round was big for court.
That was the most we watch.
So I kind of get to court.
That's kind of what we do. So fucking
terrible or or you, me and Eddie.
You'd be arguing that Brian's watching
the bride a dropped some serious
knowledge.
There's credit.
Well shut up and he's right.
He's spot on. Nothing.
I'm watching like every beat that my bed
and he likes shot. I've know he did it.
What do I do?
Oh,
what the fuck were we just talking
about before that and the idea? Yeah,
we were talking to, it's tough to get,
we need a court stenographer in here.
I know.
Pull up records.
It's true in mill is I want to
start taking that pistol class.
Fucking do it. Do you want to, do you
want to, oh, we were talking about acting.
I just got ready. I want you to get
back in acting. Well, my spin off,
we were talking about my spinner.
I'll do it. I'll do Brian's show.
Last thing I did is Kevin James
movie because Kevin's my buddy.
I heard you are good in that.
It's fun. It's fun. I would
love, I want you to do my,
it'd be great. You come on my
show, Brandon, let me look here.
Cause I got to work with the
Leslie Bibb from Talladega Nights.
Which ones that, um, she's uh,
she's, she's, she's the girl.
They said, can you kind of get
on that car, ride it like a pony.
He's fucking hilarious.
Real life in real life.
Like hanging out and talking to her.
She's hilarious. She's so fucking silly.
She's really silly.
Really smart.
You're really getting under the new
show out and he's back to acting like a
straight up Siri said he did a movie
on Netflix. He did a movie on Netflix.
Right now he's doing a series on CBS
that apparently is doing really well.
It's an excellent actor, man.
He's really good at that.
He's really good like
classic Sitcom actor.
He knows how to do that and that form
he a master. I fucking loved him in. Uh,
and uh, what's the movie? Will
Smith. Oh, Yay. Yeah, the one, yeah,
the Will Smith was like
the dating advice guy.
Hitch hitch June one of my favorite
movies. I thought he was great in that.
How do you spell Leslie's
last name? Bebe. Right. Okay.
Ben Saunders winter by
decision were wrong. Wow.
Earned good job back. I
was off. I apologize. Yeah,
I felt like he was winning the standups,
particularly in the first and second
round and he looked good on the outside.
Swollen about the eyes there.
I heard Kevin James was a
beast of a comic too. Oh,
he's hilarious. Great. Stand up. Great.
You know, he's just still doing sort of,
he uh,
takes a lot of time off and then go and
do like theaters tours and does theaters
and shit money.
But since he's a veteran is it,
he doesn't have to do a lot of spots.
You can just go to those theaters.
Can we get to do those
theories if he wants to,
but honestly in order to
really be on top of your game,
you gotta do the clubs. It's
like yeah, it's like yeah,
I mean it's not that he's not going to
be great and he's going to rehearse and
he's going to go through all of this
stuff and if he does a few of those in a
row he'll get right back into shape again.
But the thing about standup is in
order to be like you, like your, you,
you go out of shape. If you
take a week off, rhythm timing,
everything from it too.
And sometimes for me where I get
scrambled is I'll do a UFC on the weekend,
then I'll work on Sunday night or you
know like work the night after the UFC,
whatever it is. And I'm scrambled cause
my brain is still in MMA mode. Yeah,
it's like commentary mode take. So like,
like in order like to be in the groove,
like if you're doing a big
show on Saturday night,
ideally you want to work like Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, maybe Friday too.
And then gear up for Saturday.
You know, it's like you a tune up,
you gotta you gotta keep, keep
sharp. And when I do a lot of sets,
like I'll do like three sets on Wednesday,
three sets on a Thursday,
I come into Friday, I'm
just loose. It's all,
it's all in the groove and you feel it.
You feel like efficient.
Like on a Thursday when they haven't
done standing monologue Thursday on the
road and by, by Saturday you've done
five shows, five hours of comedy or just,
yeah, we'll be told me to
start doing some stamp because
I would, we would do a lifeline.
The kid at theaters, right.
We'd start with 10 minutes of stand up
and like, Dad, I can't go one month there,
take three months off and go in from this
theater. I got start doing something.
Yeah. And in between. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no substitute for actually
going on stage. And for you.
Would it be fun anyway,
man,
just do open mic nights and
all these bullshit spots
and did split seven minutes.
What I'm encouraged with Brandon is
that he just changes it every time.
Like he's always writing. He's
always, he's always carving it,
changing and taking out words, adding
things because that's sexy. Bitch.
This a fight right here. I was talking
about me by like track that be so rude.
Would be so rude. Was talking about
myself. This is a weird fight man.
Or there was no one to sell this
right now. Well, yeah, I mean it's,
it's one of those things, there's
literally no one's talking about it.
I mean it's,
this is like maybe one of the least hyped
up world championship fights in recent
memory. I feel like maybe Dana was
on vacation and came back to like,
you booked what? Well, I just
don't know what else they can do.
I mean you have this fight at one
45 you're trying to book Cyborg.
Cyborg keeps canceling. Then
they test her. She pisses hot.
Now you're fucked because
now she's out forever.
Then you stack the rest of the card and
they didn't have the fights. They did.
They literally didn't have the fights
and then now the fighters available,
they didn't know what to do.
And this is a fucking not like if you
want her to make a star at a Holly Holm
wrong fight,
wrong fight.
Cause Germain de Randamie is a fucking
nasty kickboxer and a real legit multiple
time world Moy Thai champion.
And when she's presented with
someone like home who is uh,
an excellent Stryker,
you know,
I think 18 time world boxing champion
or something crazy like that,
you know that Holly Holm is
going to be striking with her.
Well Dan is where Germane to random.
He shines her number one issue in MMA.
Just been girls holding onto her, taking
her down. You know, you seen grappling.
It's not Holly. Holly stopped
me. Holly, Ken do that to girls.
But that's also how she lost her title.
She got choked out thing
you this honor thing. Yeah.
So like when you saw in the Valentina
Shevchenko fight was when Holly fights a
nut. Like Valentino is one
of the best super high level,
most technical strikers,
uh, in women's MMA.
And she kept using that check ride
hook and she was kicking her a lot,
like working the legs a lot. And she is
bitter by a clear cut, unanimous decision.
So I feel like this is a super
dangerous fight for home.
She's lost two and a foe, two in a
row for the first time in her career.
She gets choked out by me, Hsa and
then she loses her next fight, um,
against Valentina Shevchenko. So I feel
like this is a real dangerous fight.
Tufts sell,
she loses this one super tough center
in a row and she's the girl knocked out
Ronda Rousey.
I mean that's,
that's her main claim to fame is
that highlight reel left high care.
The first one to do it. And it's pretty
well she was the strange because she,
yeah, she outclassed or how
crazy are these fights? Look
at me. Look, you have here,
you have eaten shock ray versus
Tim Bolts. Like what? Who saw that?
How weird. Yeah. I mean, Tim boats just
knocks out. Um, uh, what's his face?
I'm hopping on the towel. That's right.
Yeah. I mean, huge fight for him. I mean,
hot on a towel I think was number six
and Boesch knocked him out. So look,
Boesch jumps into the top 10 with
that boasts just will not go away.
But just for shock array,
it's gotta be pissing him off because
he's been knocking at the fucking door for
a title forever. Craze and, and
now and then. Yeah, that's true.
Well he's just waiting marrow
beats him by a small amount,
but then pisses hot.
Remember?
So this is Ben Yoel
Romero Romero comes back,
smashes Chris Weidman. She smashes Chris
Weidman, so he gets the title shot.
Meanwhile, Jack always got to
be like, what in the fuck man,
you just sit sitting there while
Bisbing fights Henderson, you know,
I thought I was going to be next pice.
Pin Gets Henderson. He beat Tennessee now.
Bisbee he's got to fight Yo.
Well,
which gray zone is dangerous besides
low vol is the second most dangerous.
I mean, you know, I think
that'd be phenomenal. I think.
I think he'd beats almost any of
the porch. Well, he's really good,
but you know what, Yo el caught him
with that wicked spinning back fist.
I want to see it as a fight.
Luke Rockhold again.
Want to see what happens. They almost
did, but Luke fucked his knee up. Yeah,
they are supposed to fight in Australia.
I think Luke had, did he have surgery?
Did you just do like PRP injections
or some shit? I'm not sure. Yeah,
he's setting again.
I think he's done a serious
seriously fucked up knee for a while.
Even though he's training now.
It keeps kicking with his right knee only.
I see about 58 yeah,
he's about 58 no,
it's a weathered 58 til, well, listen,
no one's had more fucking miles on
their body then our boy in that e and T.
Mccall can't even make a fist.
He can't make it a fight when
you can't make it fit. Dude, he,
if you haven't seen him,
Brian,
he makes a fist is his index finger
on his right hand is like that. Oh,
I could never, and what I'm doing for
people that are listening here is, uh,
like if I was playing pool and I had a,
a queue where she tucked under my
finger yet, like I'm pulling a trigger,
like he can't make a full fist is
his hands been broken so many times.
He's such a little monster to the Travis
Brown and I'm Derrick Lewis is on that
string fight for Travis. Ooh, Dustin
Poirier. Jim Miller's on that card. Ooh,
it's Travis.
Is Travis Eve,
is that actually down there getting
Dustin ready for that fight?
Is Travis Brown still and Edmonds Camp?
I don't know.
I don't know. I assume so.
Yeah, I assume so. Because I,
we heard from Rhonda or she's still
been radio silent. She posted a pay,
a inspirational quote on
Instagram. Yeah. Which is awesome.
Was it a Harry Potter called J K
Rawlings? Is that what it was? Yeah.
At JK Rawlings quote, which is, uh,
even rock bottom has the wiggle room.
That's a quote from,
what's his name? What's our
boy? That's a great, um,
even rock bottom has wiggle room. That's
hilarious. What's our boy? Ah, Don.
Dot. Merera. Yes. Yeah, he's, he
said, he said we had dinner then
he said even rock bottom has
we'll call room sign and went,
that's fucking hilarious.
Hilarious.
I'm going out to dinner we were at and
the best restaurant on the planet goes
there every night they'll come. It's the
best restaurant. Wait, listen. I go home,
I get some sleep.
I mean you can come hang and have an
amazing meal for an hour with Joe on this
one. Go home, go to sleep.
Tumbling. If you're going out
on a Thursday night at mid.
So what? I wasn't, my dad was
out of the 11 every night.
I was doing sets every night I
get up in the morning buddy. Yeah.
I don't like my mornings
to be fucked a man.
Yo come out to dinner once in a while.
I actually do go to yoga.
I know you say you do, but
I really do. You do? Well, I
really, I see, I see. Yeah.
Your girl posts on the yoga teacher,
he has to take pictures and shit
with your shirt off. Right, because
she looks like a super flexible.
So I think that yoga is one of the most
important things I've done over the past
few years. I really do. It's
making a giant difference.
I try to do it three times a week
now. Giant difference. The way I feel.
Relaxation, flexibility. I'm down.
I mean I'm a back to a
full split with no like uh,
no strain at all. I could just
drop right down. Hot Yoga. Yes.
That's shit stresses me out man. They're
relaxing. It's not, it's not relaxing.
It's brutal. Yeah, it's brewed
when you're done, you feel great.
My favorite thing right now is to
fucking torture myself for 90 minutes.
Hot Yoga and then go
right into a cold shower.
Cause right now it's January so
the water's really fucking cold.
So you're going there,
you're hurting like barely getting
through like the last 10 minutes of a hot
yoga class. Yeah. Like you
barely can make it through tax.
You're fucked up and thought it was 60
booze 90 it'll ruin your fucking week.
Yeah, I have it where you're like,
know what you mean? 45 minutes.
Let's go 15 oh dude. Wow. That's
another half an hour. Yeah, I took some,
I love it at La. What does this Cody
Garbrandt it's, it's the snakes. Oh Wow.
Who made that?
Oh,
he should sell those for shirts
on black money. Sell posters,
shirts. Do you know who that's
signifying? You know what, God, everybody,
come on guys. I'm gonna
do so right. Medusa.
[inaudible] and she turned to just don't,
what's fucked up man is that
Conor McGregor called him a snake
and it's never let off. Never.
Connor says he's a fucking snake.
And everybody was like,
why stamp stamped his forehead with it?
There's nothing about Tj. Why they
didn't make no sense what I heard.
And he left the can allow team Alpha
male was his brothers and he left that
Catherine went with Duane Ludwig and he
went to muscle farm and they were like,
fuck you. You know what they
needed like knew at that point.
Well, it's not, listen,
his loyalty was to his own future and he
felt like his best chance to get better
was not with team Alpha male.
And he was clearly the right choice
champion when he felt like he, yeah,
and he felt like his choice was to go
with Duane Ludwig cause he felt like Duane
Ludwig had some, a bond
with him and a deep, deep,
deep pool of knowledge and together
they jelled well. It was the right move,
but it was the right move for him maybe.
What do you mean it's became world champ,
but how close was he really to those
guys? See, here's the thing man.
It's like how you can't work this out.
There's not a way to work it out
where you're still with Tina trial.
I don't know. Listen, I'm just being,
I'm just playing devil's advocate.
I'm a huge file. He would go back
to Alpha male and then go to,
I'm a huge Duane fan and I'm a,
I'm a huge Tj Fan,
but I'm also a huge Alpha male fan, you
know, and I'm also a huge fan of loyalty.
It's also a team sport does not a team
sport and that's where it gets weird,
super weird, super weird.
You know what I mean?
If there's another guy that's in one 35,
like Cody who's coming up, coming up hot,
clearly coming up, coming up, hot,
knocking, everybody dead, you know,
smashing Thomas Almeda,
you know,
knocking on the door and then wants up
winning the title in his first attempt,
the first guy to fucking beat the shit
out of Dominick Cruz like that. I mean,
the only guy that beat Dominick Cruz
before was your riot and Uriah economy and
a gay teen beat the shit caught.
I would say it that way,
class it was m and a being, you
know, with the margin for error.
If your priority is loyalty,
which I'm a huge fan of loyalty over,
uh, improve, that could improve and
change your style, then you're gonna get,
you're gonna get left behind. There's no,
there's no mercy in this. You're right.
No, you're right. No mercy. You're right.
You're right. I'm not arguing with you.
And they say no mercy, no mercy.
He said, I'm moving. So true.
There is no,
there is no 100% but there's also,
there's also like brotherhood and
friendship and I feel like there's almost,
there's almost always a way to do
things different. And I don't know.
I don't know if they did the right thing.
I don't know what happened. I don't,
I wasn't there, but it's what
the, here's my point results.
Fascinating in terms of the matchup
now and now that they're going,
I think it's a giant move to do
that on the ultimate fighter.
It's fucking huge because it might be
the one thing that gets a lot of fans,
even though the cutting the budget,
are they cutting the budget?
How do you know this? A deep inside
on the ultimate fighter there. Yeah,
they're cutting the budget. How so?
Who are they not paying as much?
There's the whole production thing.
Cause the UFC used to do it.
Now they're going to outsource.
Mm hmm. Well it might be better.
It could be better. Get people who are
trying to make a name for themselves.
You fucker never, no ma'am.
All I know is lately those,
when they do the match ups from the
ultimate fighter, it usually it does.
It doesn't build it from me as much.
Tell you what men,
not a whole lot of shit makes me feel bad.
These goddamn poverty commercials,
they make me feel worse than anything.
Maintain the world. You know what?
You see people like little kids.
We know it fucked him up
even more when the show,
the animals for whatever reason,
tucked up my heart more than humans.
You got a problem,
you should go to a doctor
and the Kabam above
animals hate the see that.
I hate to see that,
but I hate more to see little kids
who don't have any singing behind it.
Yeah. Yeah, and I just start dishing.
Same Shit guys. Guys, listen more. I said,
well, it's, it's girls. Great.
Callan would fuck I put
him in that category.
Girls who were just really Carlson,
Brian Callen would have like a six month
intense relationship with before she
fucking change your number.
Earth and mothers who are really crowded.
Mother's earth mothers, women. You're
saying Sarah McLaughlin scenes that right?
Like little beads around her
ankle with luck, some strings,
wines from hemp twine. I was
driving down. Good red flags.
Good red flags for sure.
Marcin Hell Joe Lozan him.
He's young about a shit load of fired up.
Yeah man. He now, he came from Beltour,
correct? Correct. A
lot of fights with door
built tour. Is that right Jamie?
Only 24 show Lowe's on his head.
Some motherfucking battles said
he's got a nice body out loud.
So he lost a dear you.
When was the last fight before that?
He doesn't have a wave and Justin and
Bella tour, but he lost a we'll Brooks.
Okay,
so he lost the title.
We'll books lost a title fight rather to
we'll Brooks five round fight this bell
tour. Have any other five round
fights other than title fights.
They don't write ever.
So that was his first loss since way
back in 2013 when you fought Dave Jensen
and he'd be so beat Dave Jensen and
his last belt or fights or lost to him.
And then he beat him his last fight,
one fight against Willowbrook that he
didn't get little books. And little horse.
He's tough guy. Who stopped.
Well Brooks, somebody's laughing.
He hears I'm rib. Right? Who
did, he was looking good.
Who beat him? Someone big cowboy
Oliveira. Yes, and he missed wages.
I'll tell me a little bit,
but he missed weight pounds.
It was like fuck it and really get all
mad. He like grabbed the mic, got mad.
He's like, he was talking shit at Wayne.
It's like Bro, you missed it by 40 pounds.
Should even be allowed to fight
with like talking about, yeah,
he missed weight by, it might have
been like eight pounds a mountain.
He just said fuck it. Miss Weight by
Jamie. Want to say it was like 12 okay.
Here's Joe Lozan powerful Boston.
He's got a lot of savage in him and
Marcin held real interesting fight.
Let's see how this goes. Just
jumped a guard, both of you.
Here's the thing about health.
I don't think held has the same
kind of boxing that Lozan has.
Lozan very sharp with a standout.
I wouldn't call it sharp because he
does that shell up and I feel like
especially elite out I his
fight and then before that,
remember that Melvin Gallard Fight Cracked
Melvin with a jab and then choked him
the fuck out.
Cause Melvin got a little,
well Malvin was fucking people up back
then in Melbourne whilst wild wild card.
Wild cat. Yeah. Who
knows? Like with Melvin,
he was one of the first guys
to test positive for cocaine.
I was like [inaudible]
here's the thing about cocaine
that she's also like, you know,
Shim for like two days. He's also
like no shit. And it was a PPO.
It was post UFC fight
five point fives over.
That's what Oliveira was 5.5 pounds over
when he fought wheel Brooks and he came
in. Ooh. Wow. That should help you get
tore up in some states they wouldn't load.
Wouldn't allow that.
Like I don't think New York would
have allowed that New York stroller,
hard elbows by Lozan. These are fucking
nasty elbows by Lowe's on Marcy Helton.
Big trouble. Mt. Sion pig.
Oh, when he went for it,
he went for a Greg still God, he's still
got the army still at the arm. Oh Wow.
Now helds got the leg. Oh Damn.
Lozan with a fucking vicious,
he's trying to hit that performance
on the night bonus and be the all time
leader. Those are the
Travis Brown elbows, man.
Those elbows from that single Tom
about that old Travis. Yes ma'am. Mass,
not the single rather, but the wide
stance to take down defense. Josh,
Josh Barnett,
Gonzaga man,
Travis Brown man, you still fuck
people up. But those elbows,
he changed that position
for a lot of people.
And Joe Lozan just took a page out of
his book. It's still illegal to go from,
from 12 to six, right? Yeah. I don't
understand how that didn't get changed.
I really don't understand it.
I understand that they wanted to change
a bunch of shit and I think they did a
good job with most of it. Someone made
a real good point though about um, the,
uh, the new rules about, uh,
how many points of contact you have
on the ground three now. Yeah. Yeah.
So if you have three,
it's legal.
So if you have two feet on the ground
and the hand on the ground, it's legal.
But here's the thing, man. Did you see
that? You saw the Tim means fight with um,
uh, all of, so that guy over here who
came in overweight, that's just Karma. God
enjoy the,
he had one knee down,
one knee down and only one knee down.
Beautiful takedown down by Marcin.
Strong grappling by Marcy.
Nice.
Marson but Joe [inaudible] very good
at getting back up. Two minutes.
Could be interesting turns in Mersey Week.
Definitely more debt or decorated when
it comes to Jujitsu. Oh yeah, for sure.
For sure. But again, Emma
made just a little different
and those hands a monster.
Right. And Lozan has already
cracked him with a few elbows.
So we'll see like where Marcin his
head's at now, you know, I mean,
who knows where he's at right now. He
might be on, you know, they've also given,
my team sent no Gimmie's they said, oh,
you're from Bella tour. That's cool.
You're going to get first. Who? They give
him a Diego Sanchez and lost to Diego.
And then in Lozan his last fight,
he stopped Diego.
Um, what we're just talking about,
we're just talking about, oh,
we're talking about 10 means and
so the knee on the ground,
it was owned only the knee,
even its foot was off the ground
and the knee was still illegal.
So you can't have,
it's not points of contact,
even though we always refer
to it as points of contact.
John McCarthy told me
that's a bad terminology.
He said you should really
think of it as anything other.
The bottom of the foot is illegal.
Hmm.
So that, I don't know about that though.
Like what about the top of the foot?
Like what if you only have
the top of the foot down,
it's coming out.
I think they're saying though that
anything other than the the bottom of the
foot.
So the thing is,
what if a guy is shooting in a takedown
like cyborg versus Michael Page and
someone catches you with a knee coming
in while you have one knee down,
you know you're sliding in and you
get thumped in the face and knocked
unconscious. Well that's the same
as this be hit punched my life.
You get wheel kicked behind the air,
right? You're moving right into it.
Which just shame. Maybe
it's a shit happens. Rule
transition. Right, right, right,
right. Like don't be an idiot
and cut with a flying knee.
Good defense right there by Lowe's on
the brake. Knew that Hook was coming.
The right hand was coming rather,
and guy that left hand up.
I loved when they were grappling. Yeah.
High Level Shit. Real interesting.
I don't wanna see a,
he'll throw jabs.
Hmm.
It's called a fag with a left guys.
And then he came in with a
right to one of my favorite.
What are you talking about? Something
I do on the street fighter I go to,
I go 12 to six in the street fighting.
Just so you guys know, what do you think?
How much different would Emma May
be if they had three minute rounds?
Do you think you'd get a,
uh, a watered down product?
Do you get a watered down product?
Do you get more explosive and faster
paced, faster pace? Worst technique?
Is that true? What about five? Three
minute rounds. Oh, he fell down. Oh Shit.
What happened there? We'll get that
going for an arm bar. Ou on the break.
That was weird. What happened?
[inaudible] just thinking, yeah,
five three minute rounds instead of three,
five minute rounds.
Do you think that that would be better
for like [inaudible] said it best.
He said it's just too much time for
people to fight. It's like five,
five minute rounds. He goes,
no, one 25 yeah, he goes,
no one will really fight five five.
And from a guy who lost,
answered and civil with two minutes
left and surely three minutes to go time
fought a bunch of five
minute five round fights.
You know he fought against Paula Filo,
right?
Didn't he fight twice as
of five minutes where they,
you see the trail at least
then you've got on one,
the first one he got arm barred. Yeah.
The second one. And he wanted decision,
but Filo didn't make weight so he
never got the belt. Yeah, that's right.
Cause so he knows what's
going on the line. Yeah.
So was like the uncrowned champ at one
85 in the WEC really got fucked because
he won that fight. Pretty
clear. That was awesome.
One Paulo Filio was kind of going
a little kooks going cray cray,
cray cray cray cray went missing Brazil.
Some shut that Tyson Tattoo on his face.
I never found them with like amongst the
sheep or some shit. And Brazil, you know,
choking cheap. I'm sorry, I was just
weird. I just had this thought. Um,
and maybe your brother know,
uh,
I was thinking about what Floyd
did to Canelo Alvarez. Yeah.
And think about what Floyd,
oh, you're going back to this.
My brother texts you this. Yeah. And he's
a shock. Just sent you this. I just said,
might be your brother. Uh, remember that.
I just remembered the Hail Chavez Jr
and I'm Mexican. Cinco de
Mayo weekend, baby. Two years.
Way tougher than he should be. He's a
tough dude. Tougher than he should be.
In other words, you [inaudible] his dad's
fucking, he grew up wealthy with it.
I mean like kids like that,
but his dad is Julio Cesar Chavez.
Cholos ongoing for the gear teeth.
Guess what you're saying,
but didn't work out Marcy
and he slept in satin sheets.
It's rare to see his father in his fights.
His father's like Bj Penn's
family's rich as far PJ pants,
families wealthy to
look at this Joe Lozan.
It's going for the fucking leg
arm and then there's, oh my God,
he gave up the back. Ooh. Held
is so high level. High level.
What is a helds?
A jujitsu credentials.
He didn't win a Nogi gold title.
He won gold in a super high
level. Oh, look at this man.
He's wrapping up Cholos on a match to
keep that left arm on the outside though.
That's critical. I think
you've been doing git, Cynthia.
Cynthia's 12 to good moving here by Joe
Lowe's on. I like it. He's posturing op.
He's if Marcy, because if you're
going away from that left hand,
he's essentially free. He's essentially
free here if he just keeps going. Yup.
Oh No. Marcy and pulls him down. Oh, such
a strong move pulling them down there.
Joe was almost out.
A lot of people like Joe Lowe's on
would've been out the door right there.
He's almost choked here.
He's in a real bad spot here because
in order to advance in this position,
he's got to move and if he's got to move,
he's got to make sure he moves his
chin tightly pressed to his neck here.
Damn fucking sent Mike
Goldberg and the crowd. Wow.
The crowd. That's kind of weird going
nuts. Who's his replacement again?
Um, I don't know man. I don't
know cause I thought someone, Oh,
nicely done. Thought they used that
grill. Grissom. Yeah. Is that true though?
But he was on the, he was doing the pre
show like with the in in the UFC tonight.
Yeah. I sturdy it was going to do this,
but Anik cause on this, so he's not ready.
He's not doing that. Maybe
he's, maybe they're wrong.
Maybe they just hired him for more that
pre show stuff like more analysts work
instead of play by play and color. I
mean p people. Oh slows. Oh fuck it.
I'm trying to fight God. Oh, Lowe's are
attacking man. I love that about him.
Even though he's fighting a real elite
grappler. He's not afraid to dive.
I showed my face, the watchmen
getting cutoff at the checkmate door,
you know he gets to the door and check me.
He's getting cut off.
It's a long career in some wars he da
highs but I mean also the difference is
Marcin held is a really,
really high level grappler and although
Lozan is taking some chances like when
he's going for that arm bar, he gets
blocked on the way up and at it. Yeah.
Pain.
So they're keeping that skip guy on the
air even after he got caught tweeting to
himself, Huh? Yeah. How embarrassing.
It said, didn't he say he's like,
you're the man. Skip, skip. You're,
you're a fucking genius. Shit.
Tastes like a candy cane, but
didn't. He's rich as fuck man.
He say somebody else was doing it for him,
like he has somebody hired and I'll
give him nothing. He was just like, ah,
I don't know. I don't know what he said
and I don't give a fuck what he said.
The fact that it can, can, it can
ever happen. It can't ever happen.
That guy gets fucking criminalized
online. Does he? All the time, does he?
Oh, that's why he was like, great.
Some catfish account. We need some super
positive energy. I'm sorry, just from me.
That was all dudes, man, that just talk
sports. Fuck man. That, that Gig is hard,
right? Sports writer. But
it's just talking sports,
whether he's writing about it or not.
It's just Talk Baltimore, Dallas cowboys,
you know, it's, there's a big
difference between a guy like, you know,
a fucking Michael Ervin who is a
world class player who wants to talk,
oh, look at this, look at me.
Try to snatch up an arm
bar from the fucking guard
and controlling the leg so
he can't step out. Oh Dude,
this is fucking dangerous. If he submitted
him, oh, he's lost it now. He's lost it.
He's lost it.
He doesn't,
he's not nearly as close as he was just
a few minutes ago. Oh my God. No, no, no.
He's out now. He's out, dude.
He's out now. He's at home.
A black dot. No, no, no, no.
It's nowhere near. No
apologize. Oh, how dare you.
You know is like a blue belt attempt.
Well, he got real close in the beginning,
but then you see this shift from the
guard. That's when you know you can relax.
They're both outstanding.
He was at nine.
He was at like nine out of 10
and then he went back to eight.
And when you go from nine to eight
usually the other guy at this level,
easily the the guy gets out of,
I'm so envious.
Usually guys is such a knowledge
of Jujitsu. So, well listen man.
Anthony Bordain didn't start training
two is 58 that could be you, Brian.
You know what dude? Fuck it. The spinning
right now. I put my money on him.
I think you would tap you. Do you think
Anthony Word didn't cause a purple belt?
Yeah, he got a promo. I
thought he's a purple belt.
I know he's a blue a and I never do.
I don't think he's a purple belt.
I think he's still a blue belt,
but he trains regularly like,
I mean almost every day.
You know he's got tricks.
You know what they'll bluebell blue belt
and he's always traveling and he looks
a little weathered. I'll take my
boy callin him. Maybe hung over.
Callen scrappy though. Scrapping
and shape. I don't know.
I mean essentially how much sand is
this motherfucker have lesson his hours.
He's 60 years old. He hits
the booze. Hard count.
Let's set this shit up on the under
card of soldier boy Chris Brown. Okay,
I'm ready. You know what's
interesting about him in the 14 sport,
Dane is essentially like,
um,
he's a guy who has had numerous substance
problems in the past to heroin again.
Exactly. But how alcoholic, you know,
he doesn't drink when he's at home.
I mean he's not an alcoholic
and he's aware. Look,
91 a fucking Ibj F J J f New York Open,
he's every bit of six for everyone that
flows are there. 89 year old people.
He's choking, choking out. That's awesome.
[inaudible] on top at one guy's got
an inch past the guard that age.
He's awesome, pastor, broken hill. Um,
but the point is so fucked up
went bad on him because me too.
I love him too.
But the thing is it's like he has taken
all those problems that he like his
addictive tendencies and now
he's using him for Jujitsu.
He's like addicted to Jujitsu. It's all
those like triathlons and shit. Right.
You could be at least as
the same endorphins. Yeah.
That guy from the Cro mags.
What's his name? John Joseph has
a best friend. Is that his name?
I've known John since literally I
was 21 of your best friends. Yeah.
I don't think he's one of your best
friends. My Chapter John. Johnny.
Your best friends. I am. Are
you serious with the cause?
I will fucking find him and I'll
bring him in here. No jobs. What am I?
John's literally I've known John. Your
oldest runoff, you say no, no, no.
One more time. Fuck No. John
and I are old. Let's go.
If you ask John, I promise you, he
would say you're his best friend you in.
Is he in your will? We spend a lot of
time together. We wrote a script together,
man.
John 74 and John Joseph wrote a script
together and in fact back I'll say how
far go back we go.
John used to live on Ludlow in Remington
and Johnny's to have to meet me on
which is what's expensive
real estate in New York.
You and I've been there and Johnny's dad
to meet me on Houseton Street and walk
me to his apartment or I would get
jumped because nobody knew me in that
neighborhood.
That was how far back we went.
We wrote a script together and I'll
tell you a crazy story doesn't mean he's
your best friend getting jumped.
Why would you get jumped?
Because no one knew you
in that neighborhood.
That's how dangerous
jumped on Houseton stats,
how games that neighborhood was in 19
I'll tell exactly when in 1990 1991 it was
that bad dude.
You have no idea.
So just applaud at Bronxdale
walkthrough and square.
In 19 I met John in 1987 okay.
And John,
when I was with John the
first time I met him,
it was 1987 and we walked through
Tompkins Square park and it was so fucking
dangerous.
I was just,
I couldn't believe how James and
John John was very much feared.
They called John and jail. Mighty Whitey.
John was a really suggest for a well.
He did a lot of stuff.
John grew up in abandoned buildings.
They don't be general bro. What do you
go to prison John to rob? I don't yeah,
talk about it. But Anyway, point is he,
he had a problem with substances now and
now he's like this radical plant based
triathlete guy. He's in the best
shape in the world. Eats Vegan food.
He's in his 50s he does iron man. It's
fucking, he looks amazing. It's great.
It's so fucking animal when it comes to
like conditioning and and workouts and
rides his bike over night.
Sounds awesome. Sounds like,
cause she also be used to give me that.
No,
you dismissed him core and I know best
friends. I look, I mean, I said no,
no gun for 70 years. 10 no longer, and
I've known John. I knew John Ferry.
When's the last time you talked
to him? Uh, who do you know him?
A text from Jay or John. Who Do you
know better? You? Hmm. Interesting.
That's just because I spent time, but I,
I know general, how are we best friends?
If this is my space is in your top 10.
I tell you something even more important
about John [inaudible] nine isn't there.
That's the last time I texted him. It
says, merry Christmas. Merry Christmas.
He says,
show why did he call you fag fog when
he's talking and he's watching the,
I just watched a club song. Swanson don't
do who? Troy fire. Holy Shit. Amazing.
In front of the year. It's a while
ago. He and Mary Chris Essentially
to my mom. I'm going a
little too hard. Yeah. No,
but the point I'm making is
that we tell you something.
If I explain to people that
you're one of my best friends,
I don't have to go all through all
this. Zero. Everybody knows I've spent,
I know Brian counts one of your best
friends because you're with them all the
time. No, John, very everybody knows.
I talked to John. John did my podcast.
I know John Barry. Someone says, Hey,
is Eddie Bravo a friend of yours or
any brown was one of my best friends.
I don't have to say Eddie Bro.
No.
To chose what's used to hope me
and walk me through the true cause.
People are going to drop me
and go, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Texted me and said Merry Christmas.
John and I were trying to show people,
look at texts from Eddie.
We're very close.
I've got eight gigs of texts
from Eddie and they're all memes.
He always sends me fucking Hilarious,
hilarious.
Eddie Bravo has some fucking
hilarious memes in his,
in his chambers and there's savage
savage means today.
It's a totally whole new element
when it comes to losing fights.
Did when I was fight, who's wearing this
fight? Listen to something really weird.
I think it might be Lozan it is lives
on but but Marcin it's gotten some real
good positions where I have to tell
you the story about John Jones. You No,
you definitely don't. You can
stop now. No, I know each.
What you're trying to do can let it go.
I don't care about that.
You believe that or not. But listen,
listen, I've got a great story.
I'm still waiting for the lower east side.
It listened lower east side.
They were used to be a
guy who used to rap it.
He'd be naked and he used to wrap himself
in a smokey work movie. No, listen,
listen, God dammit. Fuck.
There is various,
I ave a,
there was a guy used to roll himself in
a carpet and he was naked and he would
want people to,
he would,
he would ask you to step on
him cause he would be trekking.
Finish on your podcast,
episode seven he was on your pump.
How many upset they'd be done.
I've seen John Do. I've seen John.
I saw John Give when John had no money.
John is the most generous person.
While I saw him give this homeless dude
who he knew had nowhere to stay for the,
for the night. I saw him going,
oh, you can't do that. Whoa.
He did like a wheel kick to the head
on the ground striving to go for it,
whatever. I know, well he was trying
to step over and do a triangle,
but it looked like it was almost
going for a wheel kick on the ground.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe he was trying to set up a triangle.
You really paid much attention at all
know you're just trying to defend John Doe
watching it. Watching John John's
one of the best people on it.
I believe you.
I believe it seems like it.
And I saw this documentary where they
followed him around and they followed him
on his bike riding and and is
a food preparation. You know,
he's really into eating real foods.
This is the work loads on fucked up you,
you can't just jump guard on
a guy like held like that.
Judges Eyes you lose too. Well especially
because he never had it. You know?
I mean as soon as held.
Feels like he's got guillotine on him.
He goes to side control. He passed in
the transition in the take down. Yeah,
exactly.
So that's the difference between a super
high level guy that's used to avoiding
that stuff all the time. He's
thinking two, three ahead.
Whereas maybe Lowe's ons only thinking
maybe two or one, you know, I mean he,
he saw it,
he went for it.
I admire that Lowe's on went for a bunch
of shit there me to try that arm bar
and the ground.
But I feel like that transition where
he had Marcin hurt like you know,
and then he dove on him on the
ground if he had just separated.
If you just separate,
I mean smashing with those elbows if
he had just created them subspace and
avoided the collision strike.
Yeah.
Especially when a guy of that high
caliber grappling, his default is Jujitsu,
don't you feel like by himself?
It's his natural reaction to defense.
Sometimes like scrappy
dude's like Lowe's on,
they want to prove a point maybe
and try to submit a guy like held,
which would be, oh, that makes sense. Cap
kind of an ego thing. So he decides, look,
I'm not scared to grapple with this Kyle,
do everything with this guy instead of
like sticking to a very calculated game
plan.
Yeah.
Alan Belcher did that with the Paul
Harris went buckling grab that leg.
Beautiful Defense on the ground to do.
He's one of the only fun and I saw him at,
we had an appearance together with,
for the FCF though.
And I went do I just got to,
I've never done this.
I just got to give you a fucking hug.
I was like,
I was so scared for any man who cause he
had a leg like master come in with him
to a, might've been lister who
came on Benlysta. It might've been,
he's also high level black belt.
Find out how to train to Alan Belcher
for the WHO Samar Paul Howard has fight.
Who Smart. This was spelled with an r
Paul hurray. See it be a top nine. Uh,
my space for it and fill that up. Let
me open another bottle guys. Why we,
why worry. Hey, am I in your top
nine? If it's my space, you are buddy.
I'm about seven or eight. Are
you, are you both from my staff?
Get the random New York
guy is two or three
big in from New York. Defended you
from the bumps sucking your Dick Three.
Where am I? Is that dude? I got to tell
you. I'll tell you a story about John Doe.
No, no, no, no stories about him. Please.
No mom. He was a tough guy to get tattoos.
I remember. I just shut the fuck
bro. You fucking this guy. Hey.
Oh No, no, no, no decision. Decision
securities on Marcin tiny cut.
All those kids who wins this decision? I
was on stage with them. Joe. Joe Lozan.
Ah,
oh it's but decision low first
one for held second one for Lozan
what?
But this isn't Joe Loza.
Joe on Marcin held feeling kind
of fucking salty. Wow. Walks away.
Motherfucker can't buy a winning the UFC
two two down two down was good though
that Jon Anik. No, they're
throwing them to the dogs.
Powerful Joe Lozan. Congratulations.
Awesome. As giant for him.
Powerful gray hair by a friend Anik.
Yeah. Looks like John. Go by Dean lister.
Yeah. So Dean No. Who said
yes? That is what he said.
So Dean is the guy that helped out John.
Donna,
her initially and dean is also
the guy that helped out um,
uh, Alan Belcher for the who smart
Paul Harris fight. And then of course,
like we said,
Donna train
tonin who went toe to toe cookie.
This like this position here. Matt,
when he had held Foxville there,
he had held and all sorts of trouble.
Classic Travis Browne move. Yeah. I
just feel like he should have separated,
maybe just struck and not go to Jitsu.
That's his wheelhouse.
You know what it's like.
It's like when Nogueira had fucking
frank Mir against remarried blast on that
right hand and then shoots for the guilty.
Frank Mir is a black belt through
and through them was a cold.
Let me figure this shit out.
Instead he could just pull it back and
knock them out. Yup. Different story.
Tell the story about John Joseph.
Shut
ass. If I could just get
one more judge as a story.
And do you remember early on at Frank Mir,
his career,
his first fight ever in the UFC?
He won Roberto [inaudible].
He caught him in a fucking arm
bar and snapped his arm. God.
So traveling was a world Jujitsu champion.
He was a black belt and I think Frank
Mir was a purple belt and Frank Mir just
jumped on him.
He cracked him with the shot,
took his arm and snapped it and tapped
him. You know, frank is asking the,
you'll see like, please
just let me go. He goes,
I won't even fight in the UFC and compete.
I'll fighting like Russia or some shit.
He just wants to fight.
He just wants to fight for what's
going on with the UFC isn't one that
suspension. Yeah, but if he has a
suspension, he can't fight anywhere else.
Brushes like,
oh right.
How about the lizard suit?
How about when he said
fucking inject your asshole.
Fuck you want. When he said,
he said when he used
to first be in the UFC,
he wouldn't warm up before we'd go
out to a fight. He said, yeah. I said,
what do you mean? He goes, well, to me
it's a fight. If I get in a real fight,
I'm not warmed up.
If I'm stepping in the octagon,
I'm not going to warm up for a sec.
It was like a mental thing for him.
It just makes no sense. That's not
smart. I need to talk to him. Yeah.
Well I think now he's doing it
though. Yeah, no, you get old. Well,
Valentino Shift Chenko and Julianna Pena.
Interesting fight man.
Interesting fight pinion.
You got to get that fight to the ground
yet verse Nunez is a flood fight. Well,
I mean this has got to happen first.
And then when Shevchenko um, and,
and Juliet opinion fight,
we're gonna find out a lot about how she
shove Chanko can deal with relentless
ground and pound and take downs.
Pena is fucking strong for one 35.
She malls girls got wind straight to like
a crazy, she's very tough. Yeah. Well,
she just beat cat but it
was cats comeback fight.
Cat had been out for a long time.
Huge wins. Good fight. The good fight,
a good fight for her.
And this is a big fight for her.
This is like really all the marbles,
you know that was seen as a game changer.
Valentine is fucking cheese. No
joke man. She's fucking scary.
Beat Holly on the Chicago
Card. Right. And she,
she shows that nasty fucking
right hook man where she,
she stands that southpaw stance and she
slides back and just catches you with
that check. Yeah, it's
fucking interesting fight man.
Cause this girl is as game as they come.
Pena is Super Fun.
There's some good prospects in Invicta,
US catching some of the highlights,
I think it was last
night or two nights ago.
You see that one fight where the
girl choked a girl to sleep, find,
find out what that is. It's
on, it's on the underground.
Jamie and choke the girls sleep in lost,
put her to sleep at the end of the
third round and she was out cold at the
buzzer. So it should have been end of the
fight and then they fucking went to the
judges' scorecards and the
court that the decision,
but it violates everything about
fighting that violates everything about
fighting Donald Roni Jorge Mas I'm excited
about. That's in Denver. Yeah. Good,
good. Fox Card. Serone Denver crowd.
Jorge Mosfet. It looks so damn good.
But he's, I think Donald's got,
they're both very good. Hurry.
Mosfets I'll just be up. Jake Ellenberger
and his last fight, he's a big,
big victory for him and Mazda
doll was super sneaky. Real.
That's such a good matchup when boxer.
Excellent boxer. Not just a great boxer.
Very good. Take down defense. Very
good submissions. You get everything.
You remember.
He's the original backyard brawler too.
And he's fighting Donald though.
He was in the Kimbo slice backyard balls.
We fought bare knuckle in Miami. Yeah.
One of my favorite days on Youtube,
man fight you bare knuckle. And
He, he's a schooled boxer though.
He'd seemed to educate and get it
everything very good at everything.
He's a legit 100% mixed martial
artists. Hey, did you see, uh,
Robbie Lawler left? Att said, deuces. Why?
Where does he's just inject themselves
that new young blood and fucking get it.
Go to Mancini's fucking ways that
legal, that would be legal. Right?
They can't Sanaa, they just
gonna stop you. They won't
even know you did it. Yeah.
Or you get somebody who can get the
young guy even allowed to do an ivy blown
blood dope with a young fucking upon.
Is this John Wick two,
cause I might be all in.
He drives Holy Shit.
Shit.
Deep vineyards. Those mouth.
John Wick. Not only does he
drive a muscle car, he uh,
he,
oh look at this in the motorcycle and
they killed his dog and that's why you had
to fuck everybody up. John. My
first John Wick. So underrated. Oh,
it's a great fucking time. I saw him
at Starbucks. I'm gonna Shit my pants.
He's tall, isn't he? He's a
lot taller. Jumped on a Harley.
Do you know what his national joint, you
know what? He's half Japanese. No Korean.
No Gay.
I like your attitude so far.
More guesses but not Filipino either.
Keep, keep guessing what he's half because
one side's white and the other side,
if I go James Kelly or John
[inaudible] not rushing,
I'm going to have to have you keep
guessing. I don't give a fuck.
It's come up with, it's important
just to come up. Hold on. Hold on.
Let me look at his face. Look
Chinese. Okay. No, just say Asia.
These guys sat and chat. Tell me
Shit you're telling microphone off.
That's what it is. That's what
it is. What? And after this,
I got to John Justice story,
but listen to this one more real quick.
Can you believe it?
He's half Samoan.
I can't believe you even bothered
his fucking waste our time shuffling.
It's a tough one. But he's big. He's
so big. He's tall. He's six, two
easy. Hey, how much excited about just
getting money. Did he make off Matrix? Uh,
hundreds. Hundreds of millions. Darlene.
He bought like all the stunt guys.
Harley's, I think that don't mean
shit. Wow. He's so rich. Yeah.
I just loved that movie,
man.
I look at the stupid movie and it's
ridiculous and it's unrealistic,
but I like a guy who drives a muscle
car and fucks everybody. I miss,
I never saw any solo. There's no
sidekick. He cough. No. Hell Yeah,
I'm Cobra with some esters.
Bet your sweet ass this.
And he comes out and he's got a match
in his mouth. He drove the old car.
That cool old car was it? What was it
up? Okay, here's the, what is the fight?
What is the fight, Jamie? What does
it say? He where she gets, okay,
well we'll find out who it was, but
check this out. Watch the transition.
This is the end of the fight.
Check it out.
So there's a scramble and in the
scramble, okay, well this is way later,
but the girl catches like a room naked,
choke from the side and puts the
girls asleep. She's hanging out.
Buzzer watch gets up.
Girls out cold fights over
game over game over 100% kill.
That girl is out too fucking cold.
Like [inaudible] seconds.
Powerful Gracie Baha on the booty right
in front of you as you cannot have good
representation. Find out who it
was. Young Jamie. It's his hog.
Haga well just find out who it was.
If I just find out who was hug up,
put him on an actual names. Well it,
let's find the actual names of both girls.
Tell me what's happening. They've to
last night, so see if you could find it.
But anyway, point being it's terrible
officiating when someone's asleep,
the fights over period.
End of discussion.
She's like getting knocked out with one
second ago. It doesn't just because, oh,
you're out cold,
but Dang,
there's the bell out girls trying
to fight in UFC too. Right.
Then she got on the mic. I was like,
put me in the fucking, you'll see it.
It's just one. Let me see what she goes
in the UFC and I didn't see her fight.
That's Kinda hot. I saw a few
seconds of her fight, but I had it.
I was running after this one girl on this
card that will knock your dick in the
dirt. Hold on Jamie. Say it
again. Jamie. Amy Montenegro.
It's if she defeated Celine Haiga v
Vienna unanimous decision while being
unconscious type moved. Girl.
Fuck that. So in my world,
Celine Haiga wins, but we don't
live in the mountains. No, no, they,
they change that.
They really weren't stats that fight can,
there's no way that stays. They reversed
that. They reversed that. You can't,
you can't have that. You can't
have that. That, that, that,
that's an offense to find a j pal.
Hey,
let's go ahead and call it the
girl at one. At one 45 though. Huh?
I'm kind of neat.
Some fucking contenders up there.
It says was at the Buzzer and she lost.
She put her asleep.
Still loses on scorecards. So what?
That's that's bad officiating. Cause yeah,
she was all before the bell rang. Exactly.
The swings over in fights over ref air.
Yeah. The ref made a huge mistake.
He fucked up. They should appeal.
They'll which state is that in? If they
don't win? It's a huge injustice. No.
When I will fly out there and
piss on you say Kansas City,
Missouri, get your shit together.
Your chiefs already fucking lost.
Figured this guy's taekwondo
reminds me of me when I was young.
Shut your fucking mouth.
Yes.
All right. Don't wait before you even
get to the be putting babies in it.
I'm like, all right, I'll replay the video
of your sidekick lesson guys, my wheels,
I'll just sit at a recording.
Gold things.
Glad there's no video of my wheel
kick in the air. I've seen it. Dammit.
These worth every live show.
If they ask for it,
B o two is Austin and I'm
in jeans. I'm like, Nah, eh.
You wear athletic shoes cause you
know they're going to ask Brendan Cha.
I forgot that Sean sherk
knockout. That's Shawn shirt. Oh,
back in the day to remember Pete.
I was texting this the other day at
a random thought about Sean shirt.
Cause my brain is very strange. He was
a beast. He's a piece. It was a beast.
You know I remember for it though.
Shitty shitty teeth though.
They were like a real, like a real
maaco shark's teeth. Very sharp teeth.
I don't remember that at all.
I know superficial.
I keep checking it all text.
Joe Remembers Diego. Not at all.
My picture from structured smiling. I
know Brendan, I'll pick up some stuff.
There's this teeth looks totally
normal. Handsome guy, good clean,
its bottom teeth, teeth, get it. All
those teeth. Small guy. I don't see,
I don't get it looks like a jigsaw puzzle.
You're so weird.
Would you get your teeth
fixed if you were him?
Would that be before or after
you got your fake Tan? Like if
he's all natural? Oh yeah. Videos.
They show him with like white
weighted vest and climbing up stairs.
Just this little fucking get some of the
most insane strength and conditioning
workouts.
He was Jack Shark and you ever fucking
forget it and he had a tunnel under his
house and went straight to Mexico
and that's what all of his vitamins,
all his fucking shark blood,
all his bull shark blood,
just pull it right out of was shark.
They would grind up great white sharks,
dicks and put it in a protein
shake for him every morning.
He was such a savage for a while.
Oh Man.
We lost a Bj and then ran out of the
arena. They found him underneath the car.
Well, he's trying to hide chewing on the
muffler test. Right. That's not true.
They're trying to test him.
No,
he was fucking Bob because Bj through
a flying knee and knocked him out.
Bj beat the shit out of him and then he
ran under MGM. It was under a van. Look,
he looks very fine man. I love
that. This goes one of two ways.
Either we feel really bad for beach and
he gets just outclassed by young line or
I think it's a fucking five rounds scrap.
Well this,
it's not going to be five round.
Look how fucking intense Bj looks,
man say he's never fought anybody
with this kind of style. Yeah,
no one has a style,
can't mimic is very good at
scrambling off of his back too.
He's really good from the bottom,
and that's going to be really interesting
because Bj has a fucking crushing top
game and he had a crushing top game at
55 and above at one 45 which is where
he's at. And apparently he's
been making 45 easy and you know,
he just is super focused on cardio's but
train at Jackson's for a long time now
because he's had two cancellations,
one injury cancellation,
one ivy cancellation.
He took an ivy out of competition
because he was dehydrated, hard,
hard training session and was honest
about it. Just said, yeah, you know,
I took an ivy, I just had some water
putting in his body. It's nothing.
It really is nothing.
This was in the La cartoon and they
pulled him from the card because of that.
So he's had a ton of time.
The positive is he's at a ton
of time and he's never wavered.
He's been at Jackson's a whole time.
How old is he now?
BJ's 38 it's not any as Carrillo.
He has Winkeljohn his corner
and Jackson coach's corner,
man pearls and excellent boxing
coach. Excellent. Excellent box.
Perillo let's chase him.
Pro x only works with the best of the
best creme de la creme. He's, he's very,
very, and he's what Bj for a long
fucking time. Well, you know,
Bj just felt real bad about how his
fight with Frankie Edgar went and he just
just really just felt like that wasn't
him. It was a strange style. His,
he was up on his toes. He was almost
in that boxing style, which was crazy.
It wasn't even like a boxing style.
It's like his legs are so close together.
He dancing,
he thought that he thought it'd be more
efficient and it'd be used less energy.
That was the idea behind it.
And he apparently had been doing it and
camp and had been working not against
frank Yeager who didn't exist. And that
double leg. Well, it's also, you know,
you're going right in against
Frankie Edgar. This boy,
he's a young fucking lying,
so athletic.
He's so like kicking with
those crazy taekwondo kicks
and well, here's the thing.
I mean, Jay might have the best chin
in the history of fighting at this age.
You might have the best chance
still has not been knocked out.
His name's been knocking up.
He's been stopped. He got
stopped by Frankie on cuts.
You know, Frankie got on top of him and
beat the shit off. I stopped working.
Didn't knock them out, didn't
knock him out. He took shots,
got beat up by Rory McDonald when Roy
was a legit one 70 top of the food chain.
One 70 Roy beat the shit out
of him and he didn't stop him.
Nick Diaz beat the fuck out
of him when he didn't stop.
Another one has never been
knocked out. Uh, Nick Diaz,
but George Saint Pierre
stopped him. George Saint
Pierre kept him on his corner.
He kept him on a stool in between
the corner, but just overwhelmed him,
beat him up and just Malden.
When George was at the top of his game,
they stopped that fight early.
Yes.
I never root against,
I'm not rooting for anybody in this fight.
This fight for me is like Ken,
the legend comeback. I mean,
does he have it in his shell? Does you
have it in his body? Is the evidence will,
how has he been treating his body?
How has he been taking care of himself?
Where's his motivation?
You know,
does he look at this as one last shot
at redemption and then this fucking kid
who is just a assassin,
he's so good and so hungry and he's
coming up and he's so dynamic and he shows
all of this massive potential.
He has incredible creativity.
He has unbelievable dexterity
in his legs. That, uh,
Andrew feely knockout.
We're hitting with that flying
switch round kick dude. He's
no joke. He can do things that no one
else can. So like what? He's like,
he's like a top level taekwondo fighter
who also knows how to fight on the
ground.
Who also knows how to box.
He brought into host Josie Algos camp to
get them ready for, no, that wasn't him.
That was the,
the jungle.
The jungle or something like that. He's
in jungle fights. He's a different cat.
That guy's a killer too. I don't
know. Yes, he is. God dammit.
Why am I blanking on his name?
Jonas Jonas speed.
God dammit. What is his last
name? Chimp jungle fight. Champ,
Jonah speed brought in to help Josie,
Josie Aldo.
And he looks at us like Jamie, we'll
find bill or you know. Yeah, Bill Marino.
Bill Reno's a pad. Motherfucker.
But you know he's, he will.
He'll come over eventually,
I'm sure.
But he's a fight in jungle fight and he
put up a highlight reel of Jonah's Bill
Marino. Man, it's some crazy shit, but he,
that's one of the reasons why they
brought him in for Connor. Didn't work.
Didn't help. Thanks for all the
18 second bill reno doesn't have,
is that fucking pissed?
And on the left hand that contradicts
with the Irish x back then. Well,
he's also got a fucking
Iron Chin and he's a sad,
I get that nasty with his kicks man.
Testy leans way back. You can't punch him.
That was around kicked butt. Thanks. No,
I'm saying before that a switch
switch hands switch. High kick. Yeah,
he's nasty. Well, you know
what, man, there's a ton,
a ton of those guys now
all over the world. Yes.
There's a ton of those guys who are
traditional kill Kachin fighters,
traditional Moy Thai fighters,
and they're getting an MMA now.
Gaston Bolanos is making his
fucking MMA debut in [inaudible].
Is He everybody be working
on your takedowns skills?
You best work on those takedowns Kilstein
funds the standard.
You're standing with a legit moy time
master. I'm gonna go ahead and do that.
Randy couture, James, Tony Guy. Look at
how hard this guy has to hit. Look at us.
Yeah, he's, he's nasty. And then
again, then again, it's not the to say,
but he's beautiful from that
southpaw stance and he show,
he throws that nasty leg kick or a nasty
left kick rather to the body. Holy Shit.
We're about to watch BJ Penn. Fuck. Fuck
that guy. Yeah. Put Bill Marino off.
Let's focus. Let's focus
focusing guys for Brendan Shop.
How are you feeling right
now? I'm a little nervous. I
just, Bj is one of my faves.
Bryan county paying attention. This are
you thinking of John Joseph Stories?
I got a lot. I got a bunch. I
tell him and be like, you know,
last thing about John Jackson,
one more thing. If I could just,
there's this time we juiced and then we
fucked each other and then we went and
ate vegan food. I don't know. I
almost turned me into a Greek.
I dove into a crowd off of his
stage when he was in the Cro mags,
we shut the fuck up.
I was choking her story.
It was the scariest time for me
because I'm a radical, excuse me.
Come on, be Jay. It's time.
Nothing worse than seeing a legend.
Just give her a murderer.
He's finding out like the new blood.
By the way,
Bruce buffer has a blown ACL while we
screaming and jumping around up there.
Yeah. He has not had the surgery because
he does not want to take the time off of
announcing that bumper. A God damn
savage. I don't want to see the UFC,
but I Bruce buffer, he's a savage. He's
just, he's amazing. This is a proper,
is the greatest ring announcer in
the world ever crack going virtually
identical. Oh, how dare you. He's,
he's yelling out for Bj to embrace the
grind. Bj, the brace and the grind.
But this is in Mike's Mike's hometown.
Mike. Mike fucking loves him. I'm a man.
Oh yeah, he does PJ's girl. Miss Mike.
I'm sure I will stay in contact
with Mike to the day I die. Yeah.
Mike is my friend. And um, you know,
the UFC was sold to WME.
They have their own thoughts
on what they want to do and uh,
I will be friends with my Gober till the
day I die. I love that guy to sign off.
Shit. I'm so good. I didn't know what
to do. And one of those old weird,
I know videos. They didn't want to
man, you know, I don't, I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
You said terms. I know. Well,
I don't know what's going on in terms of
organizations, you know, I don't either.
I don't know. I literally know Dana and
Dana is a reason why I'm still there.
I mean, I've met Ari. He's a very
nice guy. He's a very smart guy.
He's a very successful guy.
I wished them all the best.
I'm rooting for them 100% obviously I'm
still with the company. I love them.
I'm a, it's an honor to work for
the UFC, but I have, I'm you know,
but if you're out. Oh yes. Oh,
he's the only reason why I'm there.
If Dana trophies there, but he's
like on the, I lie all the time.
I'm going to be 50 in August. I like
staying home. I like playing with my kids.
I like doing Jujitsu. I like
playing pool. I like doing yoga.
I've been rolling again. Loving it.
We're at John Shock. Machado's nice.
I've been doing a little gay role
and get less of that shit right away.
Kick to the body. Kick to the
body. Keep forehand. The three,
four 52 first round if you want to sync
is going to get no advice to Bj Penn and
I know, I know. Please shut the fuck
up. You've never had a fight in Japan.
I was in taekwondo. Master
roaster. Bj. We can take down. Oh,
he's got the clench. He
kept, he caught the kick.
Good job of stepping inside there too.
That's one thing I can,
you might want to stay offline,
Brian,
for a few days after this one to lay low
for me to talk to you. Definitely don't.
Don't look at those Facebook comments.
All right, here we go. Look, yeah,
you're trying to take BJ
down. Interesting. We'll he
ties up with that over hook.
Do you, do you ever hit that? You
know that a judo throw it gnome.
Oh look, yeah, you're on the
outside. Super Dangerous. Now Bj,
Bj is also moving to his right, which
I don't like when, yeah, your throat.
That horrible left kick. I
know, but you know what, it's,
it's weird for guys who are right
handed to move to their left.
Like you got to train it.
It's a natural reaction for whatever
reason for guys to want to move to there.
Right? So when you're fighting a guy who
is a southpaw, who was a nasty kicker,
so you have distance,
you have a distance issue to deal with,
and then you also have to mitigate the
fact that you're walking into his power
kick and yet, but remember,
you're switching constantly. Yep.
Constantly pick your poisons.
Yeah, constantly kinda get,
just got to do your thing if you're Bj.
I mean, but that's that taekwondo style.
He can fight off of either
way left or right forward.
So BJ is more of a boxing
oriented Stryker's only bucks.
He throws leg kicks and may remember he
a fucked up Diego Sanchez with a head
kick. Remember? Remember that kid's
a while ago? He has a long while ago.
But that kick to the head was what?
Uh, opened up that giant Gash. Ooh.
Nice job there by beach and relax
just a little bit and pick a shot.
Then he can get them out of, Oh, don't
say that ever. No, it's fucked up.
I don't know why you said that. I know.
Oh right. Right hand by Y'all here. See,
the thing is Bj looks in
shape and Bj looks fit.
It's just a matter of whether or not he
can get this to the ground or he can get
something going and try to SAP something.
How this young kid,
I don't know if Rodriguez fast.
Oh, you guys done with that kick?
He got stung or Bj Penn slows.
Fuck that left kick went through
the guard and it caught carrying.
Please keep your hand up and again,
he's moving to his right. See it.
I know and yeah, your is. Oh Shit.
Catch Bj in the head with the
wheel kick please. Oh my God.
Beachae speech Ariel. Oh Wow. Barely.
Barely avoided that high kick.
So what Bj's got to do is move on
the outside and then figure out the,
Oh, look at this. Oh yeah, you're
so strong. Knee to the body.
No. Has a police. This is so interesting.
This is so interesting. Hard to
find him. He's still in there.
But here's the thing. You know,
a fight can change at any moment.
So right now you got ya.
You're walking him down looking for that
big kick and you look like Bj's in a
bit of trouble.
But let's see if Bj can recover.
You got to remember Bj's been
around for a long fucking time.
He's fought a lot of tough guys. Here's,
but here's the thing. I was going to say,
here's what we haven't seen from Bj.
I don't remember Bj ever coming
back in a fight and winning.
Do you kicks? Just, I remember Bj winning,
he beat a lot of fucking guys,
but if you ever seen Bj get beat
up and just come back, Claude,
he was just looking at the class a
long time and was like, Holy Fuck,
this is not Matt Hughes.
Just the kicks man.
The kicks and from the outside from like
sidekick can't get in and either not
doing everything from a farther
distance than Bj can hit him. Yes.
Everything is like, oh,
it's 60 round kick Bach.
He's hitting him with some job jumping
front kick to the face, right hand.
Oh man, he's, he's the
high kick is there man.
He's gotta be careful cause
oh two with the right hand.
He's gotta be careful because he's
backing up. He's dropping that right hand.
Oh my God. He's getting lit up. Who's
what I didn't want to see and he's got
his back to the cage and he catches the
kick again. Oh again to
the walking it again. Yeah,
but he's taking it all in.
Then it goes onto the body to the head.
Just switch,
kick Christ. Jesus Christ ugly. It's
a switch kick in. I used to lock off.
He's doing that slide in with the right
leg looking to switch with the left in
the air. Oh, inside their
head to my, his chewing.
Bj got you so fast.
Young.
Oh Man.
But it's a guy that's a dynamic kicker
who can also box a suction advantage.
Oh, look at that low round. How
dare you kick him in the ankle.
Show a little respect.
He has such an advantage and distance.
It's almost like having a reach advantage.
Almost like being a taller fighter.
Is he kicking him with it the top
of his foot or where? The Shin?
Both and it's mixing it up.
He's mixing it up.
He's throwing taekwondo schools throwing.
Fuck. You always showing Moitai style.
It's so risky. If you hit somebody,
his elbow with the top of your foot.
What's risky? If you hit him with the
Shin, you ever hit someone's up? What?
Your shins when they check it two or
if they check with their knee. Oh Shit.
What around a big John is talking
to Bj. Bj, his corner man.
Oh Jesus Christ. Look at him. Look up at
the air. Well that ain't good for ice.
Stetting good. When you look
up at the sky, when you get
kicked also, he's 60 song.
Fuck. So what people don't
realize is when he blocked eyes,
just one hand. [inaudible] tough. Bj
has to take these shots though. Oh,
I'm telling you,
Bj might have the best chin ever.
Maybe even better than Mark Hunt.
Crazy Roy. Yeah, he's fucking up there.
When he think about the shots he's eating.
Well Roy has been knocked out.
Remember like stocks last fight
against Mark Hunt. Well, not yet. Yeah,
but he would walk away.
K Odom mean he's able to take heavyweight
underspend those are crazy shovel.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable head
getting rocked back. God, Bj King,
his ass whipped just makes me
want to eat some taco bell.
I look any excuse to hate
yourself to eat that Taco bell.
Do you want some more wine? I never
hate myself that much to have taco bell.
Have you ever had Chick-Filet though?
Cause you should celebrate that.
I fucking chick flay or Taco Bell.
Chick-Filet no, fuck Taco Bell.
That shit's for the chick fil a is
fucking. It doesn't ever eat those Sunday
Muslim Jon Jones.
Jon Jones
passed for me. That wine.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
Big John Stepping in here
fucking cow and told him
he's still moving.
God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Not yet. Not
yet. You guys. The legend. The legend.
He's not going to save him. Save him.
God Damn Yahya Rodriguez is good.
That was just like Jurassic Park.
The little who's go the base coat,
they're little goat and then everyone's
like, what's going to happen?
He was hitting on him, man. Oh Man.
Look at Bj's. Dj said I had that.
I don't know if he's pissed. I mean,
he's upset over Bj right now. They'd go,
Jurassic Park is the fucking philosophers
thought. How dare you have that? I go,
how dare you get that fucking bribed.
It's true though.
That picture above it when you
see the velocity or with the goat.
Jesus. God Damn it. So let's
take a look at the replay, man.
Hey, Bj, this go ahead and just what is,
what do you think Greg Jackson's telling
them? That's a wrap. Just saying, hey,
you got to get everything.
Could do hardest shows you the limitations
of having our boxing only style.
When you're fighting a kicker, I
go get it. Let's check it again.
I think it's that,
but look at this front kick to the face
and then a right hand behind it really
stuns him.
It's also 2017 it shows you how advanced
he kicked him on the front foot.
It was a front foot.
There's a front kick to the face
back and then a right hand behind it.
It's just his range is
different because he's kicking.
His ability is different. Everything's
different. Everything's different.
It get when you were, you're
fighting and you only have BJ. Yeah.
When you only have boxing and you're
fighting a guy who can box and also is a
dynamic kicker. You're in
such a disadvantage. Also
doesn't play the boxing game.
He's not, he doesn't do the boxing range,
which is what you're seeing in practice.
You get out there, you're
like, what the fuck is this?
2017 he's also not doing a Moitai range.
He's doing like a sport karate,
but he's also mix it up,
going to clench,
then doing crazy kicks and all this shit.
So good. He'd be GM find a little while.
Here's the most, the Guy
Amic, there's Todd Grisham.
So this is the new guy that they hired.
So this is what they hired him for
to work the desk for a while. Brian,
I think she's still can take a hit. Hit,
hit, hit the showers. I don't think so.
I think just, I think she still does. I
think they just hired this guy as well.
This guy's pretty cool cause we were
making fun of, not in a mean way,
but roast him pretty bad on the show.
And He, and he says the because what?
What'd he say? He said you and
I have the same haircut man.
And we were saying he looks like a guy
he'd rent a car from. He goes, hey,
I heard Hertz has an opening to for y'all.
Ask him if he's really, it was funny.
I love the show. Yeah. That's funny.
He's a good dude. Well, hey man,
it's maybe one of the hardest gigs to
step into at this stage of the game.
Everyone's gonna hate on you no
matter what. No matter what. Yeah.
And my stepfather was really fucking,
he's not replacing Mike.
He's not the replacement for Mike.
Like he's liking me next to Joe.
That's not so who's going to be one
thinks just because he got announced.
I think it's going to be Jon
Anik. Anik, Anik. Yeah. Yeah.
It's weird man. You know, it's like
whenever you change something, it's weird.
And what's really weird is that Goldberg's
last show was like one of our best
ever. We're laughing, flowing together.
I've known him forever. I mean,
I've known him since 1997 wow.
Yeah. Can Penn and teller?
He has been doing it forever,
man. Wow. Since 1997 hey man,
when you know you spent four fucking
billion dollars on something,
you just want to just
do whatever you want.
You want some chair on kitchen and
replaced the shower head and yeah, put,
put a fucking new staircase in.
Do you get whacked by all the made fire?
Everybody wearing Reebok? Yeah.
Fire everybody. Alright. Cream.
The Reebok deal stick during
the transition. How's that work?
I mean they have to honor all the
contracts. I can't be as soon as it's up.
W means can be like, could do
douche doubled birds, double thrown.
Double versus double birds. Now how many
more years did they have? Seven. Seven.
The signed a lifetime. No, I'm
just joking. No, I'm just joking.
I think it's up in to, um, I'm pretty
sure Reebok's like, get us the fuck out.
Hey Jamie,
crank the volume up on this because I
guarantee you they're gonna interview Bj.
If they don't,
this is a goddamn disservice.
And since he didn't go out cold,
I'd probably interview him too.
If they don't get a deal. Mike Gilbert
should jump into the Kanye West.
Taylor swift thing.
That'd be sick.
Let's see what happens here.
Well,
it's truly special athletes and night,
the featherweight contender right here,
man.
I'm not sure you could have gone any
more with the showcase and I congratulate
you. Been any worse of a mattress,
Spanish and then English.
Who's the guy in the tie? You didn't meet
it back off off your ear to translate.
You don't have to.
He speaks perfect English.
How about we just find that he threw
up on my feet once. Yeah, he did. Yeah.
He want to fight and then threw up on
me. Well, he threw up on the ground.
He like try to throw up under his
shirt and he like it landed on my feet.
You were in your nice shoes. Some proud,
some shitty wearing those workouts.
I wear some shoes that I wear
that a comfortable for the UFC.
They a fairly soft bottoms.
Nope.
I've got a fanny pack on on stage
pocket. No, he didn't tell the,
not yet a bunch of shit the other night,
but the night before that I had a fanny
pack on what I'm wearing. I was like,
here's a bunch of shoes or wear a
fanny pack number. Oh, good for you.
Because I wait to fucking, I need a way
to vain. I'm macho. I'm vain. Cro, cop,
Cro, cop and one Chuck Norris.
Procop cop wears one all the time.
And John Hopkins guys,
he, I'm easily influenced.
Take it easy and dice clay and your
boy who's Vegan and John Joseph. Yeah.
Where's that at? A leather. So was
around his nose. No leather, no
nylon. Nylon whole. He is a
hard Christian, right? Legit.
What's shoes does he wear?
A BJ stepped up, stepped up.
Anything that wasn't at the comedy store.
That's not the ice house the other night.
Look at that strong fanny pack plus a Cool
Jack and son. No, no, no. That's cool.
You not sting ray.
I'll see flashing this.
This is this texting rate with
diamonds. You're incorrect. Oh Man.
Look at that. That front kit
that makes me want to go hunting.
When I see that right there,
I should.
The three 60 round kick man goes to
the body to whatever you want on it.
Was a domination like a
total complete domination
was a strong favorite in this
fight. Max Holloway. Well,
although he's number 10 what's
up? So let's build the guy
up. That's what I think. This
guy's a killer someday in the future.
I think that's a legit fight and I
think that's an interesting fight.
The way he is. A bad motherfucker.
Max Holloway is a bad motherfucker.
It's a really interesting fight.
I agree with you. Okay. Hey,
they made Ferguson could be beneficial
for interim title. Everybody getting
tunnels. Take Pat to look at guys.
Every Revit now from now on will be an
interim title. Damn it. That'd be nice.
Wait Cubby, I'm sorry. They
made what? Tony Ferguson. Yeah,
but they made it as more true title,
which I don't understand. Wow,
that's super confusing.
It's very confusing because
Connor just won the title.
I see.
I think this is more of a sign that comes
is going to fight Floyd next cause is
probably talking to Dana like you ain't
see me anytime soon son or it's more of
a sign that they wanted to have a pay
per view card that was stacked with
championship fights. But if you keep
doing interim titles, people were like,
all right,
we get it.
Everyone's a fucking world champion
in Congress about to have a baby.
His wife's about to have a baby,
so that's going to be something
it's going to take some time. Well,
maybe he's not. I mean, he's richer
than lots of guys. That's true. I mean,
he's like,
listen,
I don't want to go through training camp
right now and experience this first kid
had a baby. Don't get some training
camp. Yeah. I mean it's a fucking man.
How bad ass is Yahya Rodriguez?
Unbelievable. That's the
coming out party folks.
Bj had on his back though.
Or is it a product of Bj being basically
a heavy bag in there and I love Bj.
It's that, but it's also, look, I
think Bj, when he was 10 years younger,
it would have been a tougher fight
for ya here. For sure. What's,
what's interesting for sure.
Way Tougher fight.
Who fucking knows this
is the problem though,
is that it's not just a matter of Bj
being a legend and Bj being an all time
great to division world champion.
Bad motherfucker without a doubt.
But his style is a boxing based attack
and then a vicious ground and pound and
vicious, a top game submission game.
Bj is not a guy, looks submits,
guy's off his back and Bj is not
necessarily a guy who kicks that much,
but so yeah. Here, who's an
outstanding kicker, best kickers.
He has just this huge advantage. Do you
know what it's like if you check window,
if you had a guy who said you
know you and you box a little bit,
if you had a guy that said, hey, let's
spar, you can kick and I'll just box.
You'd be like, well good luck with
all that. Can I kick your legs?
And he'd be like, yeah. I'd be
like, Oh, well, well you just,
you're going to have a terrible afternoon.
Yeah. Terrible. Came over, right? Yeah.
You're fucked because didn't Bj fight
didn't, am I crazy or did he fight?
I'm a cheetah. Cheetah. So
Christ as a heavyweight on the,
it's called the Rock and the Rock
and the Rock and Hawaii. No, no.
He fought [inaudible] in Japan and rumble
on the rock. He fought Carlos Con. No,
he didn't fight calls, condoms,
Lialda and rumble on the rock.
He fought go me. He beat the fuck
out of gummy memory. Brought Gomi
over to rumble on the rock. Beat the
shit out of him and strangle them.
He fought somebody out.
I think you find in a,
I want to say k one because he fought
Duane Ludwig and k one as well. I have,
I, yeah, I thought he fought
in rumble. The Rock. That's
crazy. You might be right.
I don't know that.
Jamie.
How powerful fucking tie and pocket
handkerchief for Tyron Woodley.
I like him.
Verse one boy he liked to draw.
I kind of feel like you're half,
unless George Saint Pierre comes out of
retirement, then you make an exception.
But since George Oh look at this,
just as horrible to watch man.
He's just taking that left kick
to the head. Oh, the wheel kick.
I mean this is like right away early
in a fight. He's getting staggered.
He's getting his legs kicked out for
like those WME boys made this macho man
that three 60 round kick to
than jumping front kick shit.
Oh my God. To what yard?
[inaudible] Rodriguez First
Brian or take is a fun one.
Look Yahya Rodriguez versus anyone as a
front one. I mean the kids 24 years old.
Who the fuck knows what
happens with the, I hear, yeah.
You're might not even stay at 45 he might
be stepping up to 55 of the next few
years. Might be the Mexican economy.
He might be the motherfucker.
Boom are take us 45 right number. He's,
he's right. The head of [inaudible].
He's number nine. Dude. When you say Bj
Penn get rocked like that. He sees a legs.
Give out k one heroes for me.
Where's that at?
Longest active wind streaks
in the featherweight division.
Max Holloway Gi and Joe, you're right.
Yeah, I think it was k one right? Yeah.
And before that it was
a rumble on the rocks.
And who do you find rumble on the rocks?
Back up a little bit there.
UFC go down. Way down. Keep going.
[inaudible] going me.
He fought tagging and fight someone
else and he fought Gracie. Rodrigo.
Rodrigo, Gracie. That's right.
And that was a decision, right?
That was kind of a boring fight. If I
remember correctly. Powerful Larry Land,
this referee having seen what kind of did
two, uh, any hours. What, what is your,
what is your take on Alvarez?
I mean that Connor could be that
same pattern that does that.
He has to fight Tony.
He's got to fight town.
You can't just dismiss now one like
go Khabib guts this fucking right.
You're right. I forgot about that. That's
very, and you can't ever use MMA math.
Here's why.
Rhonda Rousey submit some uh,
cat Zingano in 14 seconds.
Cats Ganos stops Amanda Nunez and the
third round Amanda Nunez Destroys Ronda
Rousey and 48 seconds.
Never ever wasn't worth based
on what that matchup styles.
It's one on one.
It's like when are you using
that translator thing that
I told you about and you
read things correctly. But
Ferguson, is that something
that where the floors and
this and he's such a bad ass,
but what a great picture man. That guy
is awesome, is so fucking good, man.
He's the best boss logic to that guy.
I liked Solartis.
Jon Jones.
Dylan Dannis is interesting because Dylan
dances are way smaller than John John.
Oh, John [inaudible] gym or wellness
stuff. That really does happen,
but I think that's like a
suggestion more than a sign fight.
Does Jon Jones have a grappling match?
Jamie Dennis joking around says,
excuse me. That was a fit, that
Dannis thing. It was a fan. Oh,
it was fan made by Boston logic though.
Wasn't it made by boss logic,
but people were just talking about
that potential matchup online. Dan.
I said he would have, doesn't
understand. I would play with him. What?
[inaudible] said that. Yeah. Oh
Jesus. You see what Jon Jones said?
It's kind of a Douche bag. He said
that about Dennis. It looks like it.
They'd go like bag.
See what Twitter understanding
that grappling match
listeners is a far cry from.
Oh yeah. Well Dillon's also 60 Dylan
Dannis is pretty elite there for a pace.
Pretty Lean. But Gary Tonin worked
him. He received the Gary Tarone.
Dylan Dennis match. Yes. You know, Tony,
Tony is one of the best in the world.
If not, yeah, he's like, he's up there.
He's in like the handful of guys
in the world right now. Chrome,
Gracie, him, you know the Eddie,
there's a few guys and John Jay,
any comments in him?
Those guys,
both of them have really revolutionized
the ground game with the leg lock attack
like we were talking about earlier.
The uh,
John Danner look at that
was that there was a,
that transition again by held would
submit Jon Jones and under eight minutes,
he doesn't understand
how much bigger John is.
John [inaudible] the shop shut down
and crush his face in publish a chance.
I just use myself though
you would not use,
you have a chance to get ahold
of his ankles are ain't nothing.
She gotta be real careful talking
shit to John. To John. Yeah, Dude.
He will run into a bitch breaker
on runaway and then fuck you up.
It's Jon Jones.
He's so much that as men on the planet
38 when you fought Henderson and
grappling match,
he submitted v Tour
Belfour with a broken arm.
He hit his elbow capsule popped dude
in an armed barge the round before.
He will take Dick Pills all night. Stay
up to six 8:00 AM and fuck your world up.
It's Jon Jones,
man.
I don't think he understands how good
John is on the ground and I don't think he
understands how strong John,
I think John will get ahold of him.
He ever see like a cow. Like one of
those praying mantis pick things up.
You're like, oh fuck is this shit. He
cradled. He liked the radio room fly.
Have you ever seen a praying mantis
kill a hummingbird? No. No. Leave it.
They kill hummingbirds. Oh, shut your
mouth. Why do you think I would say that?
I guess I knew. I bring
it up. Is he rip its face.
I don't talk about things unless
I'm absolutely sure I pull up.
I was saying no. Hold on.
Vermont. Drat drama. Drama.
She premier from hanging out,
right? Praying mantis kills. Oh my God.
Pray that. Push. Pull that back again.
Pull that back again, dude. You got to
be sure to kill. It just shows them it.
Oh really? All they caught it. But there
are ones that show the kill for sure.
So this praying Mantis,
fucking watch this. Watch
this. Oh, look at him hanging out
right there. Go ahead and sip on it.
And Budding Sis, the Hummingbird,
he just waits to the right time.
That's crazy shit. It's, it's, it's, it's
so much smaller than a hummingbird too,
which is really fucked up about it.
But insects. What? Their exoskeleton.
It's so scary. Like Lou, those little
skinny arms. He was like, well,
how has that skinny or I'm going
to fuck up a bird. Well, very well.
Here's how many pull ups I can do.
Um, you're pulling up 18 pounds,
less things,
catching hummingbirds.
So is this hummingbird trying
to fuck with a praying man?
Now he's trying to get some nectar. He
doesn't know the praying mantises there.
He knows. He knows her. They, they,
they're very aware that the threat
that of praying mantis causes.
What will Jamie, you'll find
one Jamie. If I don't see a ton,
I'm the front of Hummingbird feeders.
They sit on Hummingbird feeders. Snipers.
It's smart. Well, the hummingbirds or
she fucking stupid. If they don't move,
the hummingbirds don't see them cause
a lot of these animals that are prey
animals like deer in particular,
their,
their vision is what's called
edge detection vision. Like
they, they see movement.
You don't really see things
that well but they see movement.
That's why if you send that asap
pattern asa pattern for Cammo that like
firstlight has one of the reasons why
this camp firstlight f I r s D Delta
veteran hunters. I'm shy. I'm firstlight.
It's one of the reasons why their
pattern is so effective is like a zebras
pattern. Although that is disputed
though. Like a zebra pattern.
They think it's camouflage
white and black.
Well this is why the idea is that the
lines break up the pattern of the body and
it confuses predators when they're in.
Is that it?
Is it attacking a cat due
to pay me at the CAC on,
it's a Caltrain mantis does my
fucking hair Fenning itself.
There's so gangster man, look at it. It
just going after the cat. The cat's like,
what the fuck Jesus is it stuck on a cat?
Yeah. I grabbed it and hung onto him.
Get the fuck out and wouldn't mind seeing
that killed his cat. No, it's not man,
but how about Coyote Peterson talking
about Santa [inaudible] and what that
venom does like the one guy has
been bit by everything. He said,
look trashed a lot. Bullet ant, don't
do the centipede paid. Look at me.
What kind of stuff? Don't do it. It's the
one actually in Arizona, 13 inch legs.
He says, don't let it bite you. Yeah. Why?
What does it to those kelp
birds to no said no. He said,
he said the hardest bites the Gila monster
at the most painful because it was a
toxin that you have to say,
this car gets attacked by praying mantis.
Did I do find crack Tansen y'all dude,
they're so ferocious. We're so lucky.
Their little. Yup. I put a whole post
today of these ants dragon away this worm,
there's 10,000 trillion ants in the world
and they represent approximately the
same bio mass as all the humans.
There's 7 billion people in the
world and there's 10 trillion,
10,000 trillion ants, but here
it goes. Look at this. Look, see,
this is like a common tactic that hung
that, that praying Mantis dually. Oh,
oh damn grand by the faith.
But Dude,
how strong are those little fuckers? He
closed his beak like get over here, bitch.
He just clamped his fucking Moy Thai
clinch on that hummingbirds head.
Who? Who just pause, let them go.
So who did that? Oh, some
fuck with the gloves on.
Who's jacking off the hummingbird person?
Look at this thing was why did someone
film this and then [inaudible] you
fucking pussy. This is nature. Why are
you interfering with the natural part?
I heard the praying mantis when he did
that shit. Probably know the pray man.
It's starving now. Probably dies. Yeah,
look at this. He's got a clamp down.
I mean this is an awesome catch.
You've got to let that play hard.
That is for the premiums.
Get Ahold of a fucking hummingbird.
Got In there and so we need to
find that guy and piss on him.
You know what that's like?
That's like when you boys getting his
ass kicked and you jump in and start
throwing kicks to the head. It really
is. The guys on top, it's dirty.
He's got your boy dirty.
It's the ultimate cock block.
God Damn it.
It's isn't it crazy that praying
mantis like weight on these bad days?
There's another one.
I just thought they look gangster.
He's just sitting there and
it's hummingbird feeder.
Hey, don't they have sex?
Then rip the other one's heads off
to the HMI. Yeah. A praying mantis.
The female rips. The males had,
oh, watch how he gets him told up.
It's so crazy how they're so much
smaller than these hummingbirds. Oh,
he's getting handed on him.
No, no, no. He does that once,
but watch the second time the hummingbird
comes close and he's like, Nah,
not to days said, yeah,
try that again bitch.
Watch.
Get that gets close to Riga as man.
They know that the praying
mantis is a threat,
so the praying mantis is kind of
laying low. He, come on, give me,
the job was just so scary and freeze tag
right there. He's playing freeze tag.
Yeah. Look, he comes back and he's
like, well, I took care of that problem.
I like killed. Take your eyes
off down the hill. Attention.
Be careful of that ass first sand eat that
takes them over the edge.
What a creepy animal bite
her favorite animal. Hold on.
Is that a black widow and a going
war? Full screen please. Uh,
yes. Please. Look at that fucking
monster. Look at what a praying mantis.
Look at this. That things
are bad ass. Dude. Don't fuck
around. I've told you that.
But he's got to be
careful to black widows.
You gotta be careful there because
burst his abdomen. But here's the thing.
A black widow is not a fucking weekend.
I'm will either
pop his abdomen, one of them, one of
them might have a good moitai clinch,
but the other one has
venom. It's like, yeah,
it's like Bj Bji or like if you get
bit by a black widow, you're fucked.
Imagine if a praying mantis does game
over sadistic. Fuck with this camera. Oh,
first of all, this sadistic fuck.
Set this up like a psycho for sure.
There's a fight.
He set it up like a psycho.
I'm trying to see it in their natural
habitat. Well, what's this? Oh,
that's a hissing code. What happens
to the fucking praying mantis?
Why would this is like the guys waiting
on deck? Let's see the fucking pray.
Oh Shit. I'm out of here. Yo. Bug fights.
The spiders trying to climb the wall.
Let's see if they let them, they might've
grease up the wall with Vaseline.
It's dirty. Well, that's
what I would do. Yeah.
If I want to set up a fight to the gel
ones. No part of that. Hey, wide jelly.
The entire wall. This is good. Good. No,
I have youtube hits to get,
you're forced to fight.
Do you remember your Paramus step on
every and all these piranhas and the
goldfish.
He had his golf fishing feed gold.
I had a goldfish tank that was right next
to the [inaudible] attack and I would
scoop Goldfish, the goldfish tank and
drop into the prong. Attack the prompt.
Yeah. If you wait a couple of days, just
fly. Here's the thing, you can't wait.
You gotta wait two days, not four. They
die. No, no, no. They eat each other.
The brown is eat each other. Yes,
they do. Yes you do. You remember too,
you gotta well,
you,
I don't remember the exact days cause
this is a long ass time ago that I had
them before I, that it was illegal. Um,
I mean this is all theoretical.
I don't even know if I really heard them,
but I don't think so man.
You know what's really actually way
better than Paranas. That's totally legal.
It's barracudas. Um, I
know a dude. Oh Dude,
they have little barracudas
and people feed them.
Fish and barracudas are four
approaches. Little motherfuckers. Yeah.
And here's the thing about them.
Do you know what island dwarfism is?
It's like if you have an elephant
that it lives on an island there,
there'll be really small elephants.
It's really interesting to get huge.
But lizards on the other hand,
grow giant on islands.
That's why Komodo dragons are so big.
Komodo dragons are the largest.
Reptiles are the largest lizards. Crop
Crocodiles, the largest reptiles. Right.
I always fucked that up. But the
um, when they take these, uh,
these, um, uh, barracudas and
they put him in a smallish,
like a 500 gallon plus saltwater
tank, they'd stay, don't get that big,
but they stay ferocious. They stay
meaning mother fuckers. Yeah. See,
look at this guys got their photos. I
like when they're all big incorrect watch.
Watch when these motherfuckers decided
to feed, is there, are they feeding?
They're going to jack these minnows.
Here's a bunch of cool fucking like sick.
Let's, Oh, here he goes. He's moving in.
Don't boom, boom. Look at that speed.
He picks up how quickly just
jumps on that minnow and just,
I heard the roominess fucking the ocean.
You gotta Watch out.
They'll bite your Dick. Like he
just ate that minnow. I wonder.
It feels minerals are freshwater minnows
or salt water. Minnows could or water.
Yeah,
but that's what I'm saying.
Do you think they threw some freshwater
minnows in it? Like deal with it, but it,
sure they're super lazy.
Well, they're super fucked.
Like you're not going to let him breathe,
Huh? Ooh. Quicker. The jacket fast.
All Muslim. They Jack them so fast.
She say all muscle nursing, a fat fish,
dolphin swims 40 miles an hour through
the week. You never seen a fat fish.
Do you ever ordered Toro?
Toro is fatty tuna. Yeah,
but you ever seen him in the water then
I'll look out a shift. Fat As fuck. No,
no, no, they do. They have flip
flops on and beer in there.
Eating cake and ice cream.
I love me some fatty tour.
I'm just saying you look at and they look
pretty fucking in shape in the water.
It makes me want to do that
right now is out of shape. Fish.
That's a fat fuck fish.
I'll come off. Yeah.
Motherfuckers Twinkies eating Twinkies.
Lazy waiting for government housing.
Look at that.
That's a fat fucking tuna. That's a nice
looking too. Do you ever catch tuna? Me?
Yeah. You ever catch fish? No,
I was doing a, when I was young,
I used to fish all the time. Why Denver?
So we caught tuna in Hawaii. And then, um,
what kind of tutor with
very skipjack tuna. Yeah.
And then brought it back to the
hotel and the chef at the hotel, uh,
cooked them up or like with no fast. Oh my
gosh. So good. We h the, she me from it.
I want to go there, right. So let's get
a time share in. Hello. Hi. You guys
bring your Vegan friend John, a buddy of
mine. That guy who was your best friend.
I had a buddy of mine who bought a house.
He bought a vacation house and then
he said if I had to do it over again,
I wouldn't do it over again. He goes,
uh, just get a fucking airbnb. Yes,
you could rent a dope house
whenever you want to see. He goes,
if you have a house out there,
you feel like obligated to go there.
And he goes to the toilet breaks.
You got to hire somebody.
The sprinkler fucks up. You've
got to hire somebody. You own it.
And then you airbnb that bitch
out and make paints. But yeah,
but then she took a bunch of
people farting in your house,
but jacking off office your fucking
garbage chute. Well, I'm not renting out.
The booger knows kids taking high jumps,
high class old,
boiling their ass hole right over your
kitchen sink it just unload your buying
shit and they clean it.
You don't even know like you're in there
and I'm so glad we're making additional
income here.
You fucking
your day. Meanwhile they're
fucking boot cocky. And my dude,
did I interrupt someone? You're
basically saying I'm more important.
That's what I'm saying. I'm shitting
in a, in a, in a, in a sink.
There was a gym at Marina del Rey. Got
You. I tell you the story about the guy.
He's John Joseph there. Nope. Nope,
nope. The Gym, I wouldn't be there.
He's your best friend. Yes. In Marina
del Rey. You remember that one?
I tore my place. I told him there
was a guy used to shit and no,
it was right off of via marina.
So this guy used to shit in the shower
and he would take a shit in the shower
and they knew it was him, but because
they can't have cameras in the house,
in the gym. So it was like
going to gym, a strange city,
marina city and, and how they
know, and he would look at the guy,
he would look at the main guy who was
always trying to catch her and freaking
out and he would,
he would go have a good day and wink,
apparently I might log in.
They're like cheese grader.
Did he ask him if he shit in the sink?
Oh, and the guy would lose his mind,
but they could never prove it.
Right. So we'll just hanging around.
Why would he think that that guy did it?
Well,
because they 100% knew that the guy did
because every time he'd be in there,
he would disappear. And they started
putting two and two together.
And not only that, not only
that, he would leave a huge log,
but more importantly he would go have a
nice day and wink every time he did it
that you can't prove it. But he got
off on the fact. And at one point,
the main guy who was the one of the main,
the manager of the gym,
they had to hold him back,
loop her autumn.
The Guy I used to work out
with told me this story,
they had to hold him back because he
just is like, I'm fucking fuck it.
I don't care.
It was a customer.
I want to beat the shit out of him
because somebody had to clean up.
He got off on taking a shit in that shower
with just leave and never seen that.
I've never seen anyone take a share.
A lot of people that like
to do weird shit like that,
leave their mark somewhere and be like,
see Ya.
It's like borderline fucking
serial killer. Oh yeah. Real close.
Like then you start torturing
cats. Yes. Well it's,
it's the idea I might get caught.
So it's yet, and you know,
another profession is people breaking
in other people's houses and jerking off
in their house or in their
closet. Yes. And yes.
And so running off. Yes. And the
reason they're so disrespectful,
but that's when you know you're
not a winner. [inaudible] man,
you're not saving the world.
You're not going to be the
president of superpower or you are,
or you're like a high
functioning executive and you
get off on the fact that you
might get caught. Wait a minute.
High functioning executives,
do you know that breaking in people's
houses and jerk off on their shoes and
none.
However,
apparently it is a perversion
that affects a lot of people.
So you can be a lawyer or whatever and
you get off on the fact that you bring in
somebody house, you're jerking off in the
closet, you might get caught. Who knows?
If somebody comes home and you're come
to you, leave, you run out. That's,
that's something that affects no
matter what your socioeconomic status,
see the results and lets you set up a
camera and just assume that the idea you
might get caught. So taking a shit. So
signing people admit that they do this,
is that or they find out about
this or they catch them? No.
So in a book called a billion
wicked thoughts. These guys who,
neuroscience who studies
sexual perversion and stuff,
this is a something that a lot of
psychiatrists would deal with, right?
So you or in in in people
who have sexual perversions,
it's a recognized thing where danger,
where the ID you might get caught and
doing something behind closed doors doing
something, you know, which
would be outrageous, right?
Is something that's oppression.
He only can me say like high
high powered executives.
I always think of people that are in a
position where they're being forced to
behave in an unnatural way
and that bottles up that's
jacking off to do a weird
shit.
I mean that's like that's,
that's a big issue with businessmen
that are like really a powerful guys.
They like to have like women's shit on
them and do crazy things or dominatrix
and Jamie still jacked up when your
Yeezys well I was a dominatrix that met me
and Jim Norton in Austin.
We were eating dinner after a show
and we're hanging out. And this girl,
cause she knew that Jimmy Norton who's
a fucking pervert and a half is into
dominatrix is so she came over.
You see Dominatrix
is
terminated and he likes to do you
say is Jesus? He's in a dominatrix.
What'd you say? A of a bunch of
dominatrix. Sandy [inaudible] dear.
You can say he's into Dominic
tricks is dominate. He's into,
he's into being dominated and,
okay,
but if you have a room full of
women that work as a Dominatrix,
would he have a room full
of, did you have, you have,
it's called dominate tree? No, no.
I mean has it eliminated the
plural or is there a hurry?
So rare that never in a room. We dominate
trusses. Dominique Dominique's tricks.
So you were saying Jim
Norton likes this girl? Uh,
no, not, not. He doesn't go that deep,
but he's just a freak. Let's see. Okay,
so when he's the best, so anyway,
this girl comes over and she says,
I just want to introduce myself. My name
is, you know, madam crush, your balls,
whatever the fuck her name
is. And then she, you know,
we say come on and sit down with us,
tell stories. So she sits down with us,
you know,
she doesn't name any name,
she's an actual real pro and she starts
telling us about all these different
guys that she shits on. No, no, no, no.
Mostly wealthy businessmen,
lawyers,
people that have a lot of people that
work under them. They have their,
they have power and they're also like,
like bent.
They're all fucking pressured.
And I stone strong ass might have to act.
I dated these girls who had a chair.
She took me into our dungeon and she
had a steel chair. When you say dated,
is it like you say John Joseph's your best
friend? Ah, yes. That's a very good, I,
we had sex and she's,
she brought me to the steel chair and you
sit in this steel chair and your balls,
your balls go through the chair. When you
say you don't say you, they say the guy.
Well the Guy May, I was just observing.
I'm not into being dominated, but so,
so she, she was a tidy
up all your balls. Yes.
And so you tie your balls,
you take a string wrapping around
your balls and tie it to a chain,
to a link on the bottom of the floor.
Now you came back,
you're not going anywhere. Your
balls are our tie off to that. Well,
and then you get peed on know.
Hey,
do you want to hear Yahya Rodriguez
talk about this? Grant this,
crank this volume up. What's, I want to
hear this. I already talked about it,
but I want to hear,
I want to hear what he's saying now
because he's getting interviewed by Kenny
Florian. Let's talk about
shit. We will, we will. Shit,
uh, ideal pleaser. He wasn't on
the cake, but uh, you know, I,
I uh,
so we kinda started get to them.
I went up stretching the strategy to him.
They should have stopped
the fight a time in early.
It looked like you laid it
a lot of unanswered stripes.
Tyron Woodley making controversy.
Yes.
Uh, I actually feel like if I stopped
once she came to you on a stand up,
so I better keep a bunching I, you want
to use, they're trying to go on that.
I couldn't, you know, and uh,
look how quickly he steps to the side
too. Once a PJ goes down, wash steps,
look looking, look at that sidestep
step to get to side control and Hammer,
Hammer, Hammer, hammer
clean as possible to fight the top
for a slow build rental guy.
Try and get him.
Do you know why I got Brian?
Get his balls?
Do you know where most of the shit
videos come at Germany and Japan?
And do you know why? War and then they
filled, it goes back. She was saying,
it goes back to what you were saying.
They're very, very suppressed culture.
There's a very,
very disciplined and rigid.
Have you ever gotten done that buddy hall?
Oh Bro. They have mask. I can't do it.
And then they shit into the
mask but just can't do it.
One of my favorite pictures in the
Internet ever was from the 90s and it was
that girl, it's called, uh, it's
usually Japanese bathtub girl.
The girl's in the bathtub and she's
got her hole straight up in the air and
she's shooting a fountain of
yellow diarrhea out of her ass.
That's landing in her talking about life,
seeing that all of its various forms.
I I know as super wealthy man,
super wealthy,
don't say his name on the air, but write
it down on a piece of paper. We know.
And B, you don't know him, you know,
you know, you know somebody who knows.
Look at that,
look at that picture.
That's one of the greatest pictures
in the history. And, and, and just him
as a mascot.
That's what bouillons Sasso said,
whatever you do,
don't open my laptop and he's late. And
he put it on my trust to them and I go,
don't do that. He goes, whatever you
do, don't open my laptop and look at it.
And I was, he was right in front of
my dressing room and I had to look.
And that's what I fucking saw. And I
saw it again. I love about that picture.
She has her socks on and she's,
and she's holding her toes cause she
doesn't want to slip. Good for him.
I feel like you know you do.
I was going to say to him about
the fire that was backwards.
God dammit will Sasso diarrhea,
diarrhea on my laptop now without
that either. Why do they do that?
Why don't they do that? Do they shit on
each other? Well, the whole idea. Wow.
Look at that champion Josie Aldo.
That seems weird to me. It make sense.
It seems weird to me.
And then Max Holloway interim champion,
like what is going on when you have a
champion who didn't win the title in a
fight in the,
in the octagon,
he was awarded it after he won an
interim title against Frankie Edgar,
which is a beautiful performance
on his part. And then Max Holloway.
Where's an interim like who's within?
Think about how Max Holloway gotta.
I love Max Holloway.
He has nine fights in a row that he won,
but then he beats Anthony Pettis who's
never fun at that weight once before.
But really not a top contender,
really. Not Realistically not.
And then leaves the weight class and I
was up 55 and then you won your belt off
that, you know, it's so fucking strange.
It's weird how everyone has belts.
Well,
do you think that this is just a part of
the transition between Zuka and WME and
that is going to be like
this transitionary period
where everything powerful.
Watch Tyron Woodley Champs got good
taste and Washington, it was a Rolex.
It's a fat one. Whatever
it is, it looks good.
But the thing being leave that bad boy,
it could be an Invicta,
but the thing is it's like,
do you,
do you know there's obviously some
sort of a transition going on.
80 people have been fired, including
Goldberg, right? Yeah. It's a,
it's a crazy time.
So I think they're scrambling for stars
and I think belts brings along some sort
of ratings. I just think they're
in this feeling out peer,
this transition period that they're,
they're just trying to figure it out.
And I think that's why Dana's entertaining
this Conor McGregor fight because
what else would we talk about?
Names named something else big going
on in the UFC right now. Interesting.
Is his design, does Debbie Emmy, are they
really, or you know, this organization,
have they really been involved in
anything where the outcome is totally
unpredictable,
like combat sports?
Because like the promotion for
the Holly, uh, or excuse me,
the Rhonda fight was a perfect
example of something like,
well we really hadn't
seen it that way before.
We're really hadn't seen it go 100%
heavy towards the superstar. Right?
Hundred percent heavy. Usually it's like,
you know, you would see a promo piece,
like say if it's like
Woodley versus Wonderboy,
you would see Wonderboy highlights,
you would see Woodley highlights,
you would see ass kicking on both sides.
You'll be like, holy shit, what a fight.
I can't wait.
They didn't do that at all.
They get is the way they would do a movie.
They did it the way they
are promoted TV show.
They did it the way they would promote a
new Kiefer Sutherland series on Netflix.
You know what I'm saying? Only the star,
but, but that shouldn't say Netflix,
I should say like Fox.
That's what scares me because Dana
white when it comes to this is a genius.
He would never,
I don't think you would allow that to
happen so I'm just wondering how involved
he is cause without Dane, if you
just have WME running it, fuck,
what's it look dope though.
I'll tell you what.
I don't agree with the fact
that they ignore it. I'm a,
I'm a purist in a lot of ways when it
comes to combat sports and I think you
have to respect the
hierarchy of the champion.
I don't give a fuck who
was the famous person.
This championship thing is so
important when you have that,
if you're going to have champions,
you got to respect the champion
like whoever the fuck it is. It's,
it's super important to make a big
deal out of the fact that that person's
champion and they made like almost no
deal out of the fact that she was a
champion.
It was just weird situation but it was
really well done in terms of like getting
me amped. Does it though? I
disagree, but for me it was for me.
Look, I you're the one doing the fucking
no, no, no, no. Most of that was not me.
Most of that was like you open up
the fucking curtain, the garage door,
and you see her tech hitting the pads.
I had almost nothing in that.
The only thing that I said is I can't
imagine she's not going to come back and,
and be a, you know, what are motivated
or pumped up or whatever. By the way,
a lot of the stuff they use in those
promos. Totally out of context.
Like when I was saying that she's the
best ever, there's no one even close.
There's hurt and there's everybody
else. Yeah. You a long time ago,
that was a long time. Correct. I
did not say that for this fight. No,
it didn't say this for this place.
But you said that for the
think you said that for the
batch go. Hey, a fight. But yeah, so see
like when they're making these promos,
patching stuff they're taking,
so for me,
I have a problem with that because this
is not what I would say. Yeah. So you're,
you're using like an old quote when
she was dominating people versus a new
quote,
post head kick knockout post the emergence
of Amanda Nunez after she stopped
staring McMahon you versus a, you know
what you're seeing now in this division,
which is all this new blood coming up.
You're seeing this division percolate
and change and evolve and you're seeing
like higher level fighters come in like
Valentino Shift Chanko like Amanda Nunez,
like Holly Home.
Like you're seeing all this stuff take
place in front of you seeing this change
in the women's division the same way you
saw a change in the men's division from
97 to 2017 you're seeing that now take
place at an accelerated pace and the
women in the women's division,
so who is dominant two years ago,
like to use a quote from two years
ago, it's really not fair. I agree.
That's really not fair characterization.
Yeah, but it, but it builds the fight up,
right? It builds the fight up, but
it's not the way to do it. No, I agree.
I'm appears to. But the thing is is if
you understand this sport and you look at,
let's say you want a copy of the NFL,
the NFL would never just focus on Tom
Brady because there's a good fucking
chance Roth Lisberger wins next week.
Now imagine if they just did all promos
on New England. People were like,
what the fuck is this?
Exactly.
It's just some bullshit fucking good.
Worse than that,
what you're talking about, all promos
that aren't the champion. Yeah.
Which is worse than that.
Right?
Because you're talking about someone
who just lost by brutal knockout.
They're getting a shot right away at the
title and the idea is that even though
they lost, they lost,
but it was some bullshit.
She's now she's back back now
she's Bafta for elimination bats.
Fucking 411 just a bad.
It was a lot of bad business plan.
There was a lot of talk by
people that I don't know,
but I was listening to people talk
about it like I don't know who they are,
executive type people and I was like,
wow,
you guys have an idea of how this is
going to go down. Like they, they,
they were just super, super connected to
this idea. I don't know who they were.
I don't know if they're friends,
I don't know.
But there was a lot of people that we're
talking and then had this idea that she
was just going to go in and storm the
castle and take back with her like this.
I had a conversation with a high up exec
that a big time corporation and we're
talking to him and I'm like,
oh my, you have no idea. What
did he say to you? He, he,
he,
we were talking about Connor and Rhonda
and he was neither one you lesson none
had that one hiccup. She will never
lose again. And like that's not true.
What is a good deals is no, no
did, she would never lose getting.
She goes and he goes and
Conner, not a chance. I'm like,
what are you talking about two at
these people were talking backstage,
gods are like cues me.
These people were talking about stage and
one of them didn't know Newton and his
name.
Yeah,
and they were calling her cannon
fodder boy and I was like,
they don't know anything.
Who knows who these people
are? They could be, I mean, I don't
know who they were. Yeah, they might be.
They could be people who are friends of
people who know some people that work at
William Morris and they're backstage
dressed in fucking $2,000 suits and they
look classy. Who knows? I
don't know Willie Moore.
They shouldn't be doing anything
without going through Dana light first.
They should not be doing anything.
Yeah.
Mean the game way too long for you guys
to make any decisions without having
some sort of influence from a guy who's
come from the ground up from it going,
you can't do that. Listen, our fan base
is going to yell bullshit on this man.
And if we, if, if Rhonda doesn't win,
we are going to get fucking rain.
Connor cannon fodder. Huh?
Do you think? Yeah. Yeah.
That was the word that someone used.
Do you think that at this stage that
there should be some sort of clearly
established protocol as far as who
fights who and why you have to,
otherwise you're no different
than the WWE. Right.
Then people won't take a lot of the
interim titles and the championship fights
serious. Here's my argument against
that. Dan Henderson and Michael Bisping,
I bought it to see that fight. It was Jack
Damn tough. Cause we love Dan. I agree.
I love Dan and I love Mike and I love,
I know Mike wanted it back.
He finally got the title and he's
like, fuck this guy knocked me out.
He's got his fucking picture of him
flying through the air touching me in the
head out cold that everybody
knows what that logo is. Yeah.
He's like fuck him. He landed it twice.
Then I'm in the fight. No don't me wrong.
Matt might be fine.
It's up there.
But I think you have to have some sort
of structure where people can see what's
going on. It's just like maybe it's
like a Usada exemption exemption.
Brock Lesnar, he got away with that for
a month. You promise if you do that,
you're right. You miss out on this really
fun kind of revenge pass. Yes. The,
but then you can't say, oh, we want to be
in the next NFL. Let me ask you, the NBA,
do you think, I mean outside
of like promote, see,
you see the thing is he can't
deny. It's weird. It's like,
are you a sport where someone has
a very clear, you know like the,
like the world series.
Like you can't,
like someone can't lose a game and then
all of a sudden be in the world series.
Right, right. It's just like
there's a, there's a protocol,
like you have to go through that protocol,
but do you think that there's
a possibility you could
have something like that
some established set up but then they
could throw it to the Internet for like a
wild card can have that cannot have that.
My question now and that maybe the
UFC gets three wild cards a year.
Oh God. Oh my God. Is the people
who have an answer to that thing.
But here's the other thing. I wonder if
this an MNA young Jamie shaking his head
for the all star teams and shit,
and that's how y'all Ming is the
number one a year every year, year.
But why is it because Chinese people
is more of them? Well, technically yes,
but let me ask you, what does he
do it online? The Guy Right now,
that's the number one
forward for the warriors,
but like no one knows even not to
say his name. Is he from China? No,
his name is Josh shop with Trulia,
but he's going to,
he's the leading vote getter. Jeremy Lin
to, where's he from? I have no idea. Yeah,
Shaw's up. I don't know. Lithuanian.
Maybe. Let me ask you this question
about him and match your own.
Here's a question. Do you
think, I wonder about MMA,
whether it being champion in most of the
divisions is even that important to the
fans? In other words, what's important
to people is Conor Mcgregor, right?
Rhonda Rousey, the people that have the
co, there's something colorful about them.
Complicated people. Somebody who speaks
well. So we, we watched those guys,
but I'm not so sure that because
Michael Bisbing is champion,
that his viewership goes up as a result.
Sure. Does your mom clinically proven it?
It Championship. Terrible point.
Terrible point. And you know what?
I need you to take a break after
that. But to your point, yeah,
you can say Rhonda was the bigger stuff,
but Ronda was a different force and
reason she got so big is because she was
champion for, Rhonda was never
champion. We're not even,
but also like what she was just,
she was winning one, losing one.
It doesn't matter what she did to indulge
that whole popularity thing was very
different than Connor's approach of
Connor decided to take that exact same
approach and go do a ton of movies and
go do a ton of talk shows and go do a ton
of, do one commercial Budweisers and
entourage and all this different shit.
If he started doing that same shit,
his star would rise proportionately to
weigh her star rose and his performances
inside of the octagon with
suffer proportionately to wear.
Hers did and he didn't do
it and he's still bigger.
We were talking about that
guy that did that interview.
He's a sports guy and he was
talking about none of the other guy,
the black guy who was with them
sharp. Is that his name? Yeah,
and he had a great point. Shannon
Sharpe had a great point and he said,
Rhonda cheated on MMA.
He said,
you gotta be all in and says you can't
go and do a bunch of other shit and think
you're just so much better than everybody
else that it's never going to catch up.
It comes from another 1% or athlete
who knows exactly had all this kind of
tempting. Shannon Sharpe stuck
to the game. She didn't witness,
said it when he said it. I was
like, this guy's dead. Right.
I think this business model though,
the only problem with the business model
is that with MMA it's really hard to
invest in the champion because
of the nature of the sport.
The the belt, we'll chant like especially
on your investing for one fights, right?
But still you, but you're investing,
you're not investing for in the champion.
You're investing in the organization
and the fact that they have the best
fighters in the world, what you're doing
with each fight is promoting a fight.
What I'm saying is that you have to
respect the hierarchy of the championship.
Above all,
the champion is the champion and if
you don't respect the hierarchy of the
champion of you're somehow or another
sang that this champion ain't shit unless
this champion is fighting
Mike fucking Tyson.
When Tyson was 20 years old and just
smashed and everybody and you knew all my
God, this is going to be the
youngest ever heavyweight champion,
then you focus on that guy with the same
amount of fervor that it demands. Right?
But that's not the case here.
You know,
you're talking about an insanely like
in that particular Ronda Rousey fight it
insanely dangerous champion. Yeah.
Who just smashed me. So Tate and,
and you're talking about an x factor.
We're like,
we really don't know what we're
going to get exactly. With Ron Bass,
we put all the money in. Yeah.
Right. So you got fucking insane
you've got, but also you have an insanely
marketable champion. First of all,
the first ever openly gay
women's MMA champion and man's,
it should be never been an
openly gay MMA champion. Right.
So you have the whole Lgbtq,
whatever they are now a,
is there a name that has about a plot, but
it is, you have a bunch of people that,
but you have also a bunch of people that
respect that in a progressive people
that say, hey, this is great. Like look,
it shows how diverse the UFC is. Sure.
He's amazing. Yeah. And the stupid shit
that Meryl Streep said the other day,
like one of the reasons why she probably
said it is because she's seeing Ronda
Rousey's face plastered all
over the place, the face,
the place. And she's saying,
Hey, you know, you take women,
foreigners out of Hollywood,
you're going to be left
with football and MMA.
She doesn't understand the full
MMA like you saw tonight with Yair.
Rodriguez is 80% foreigners. It's so
wrong about that. And that's also art.
That's that jumping, spinning
back kick would be ARD. Oh,
come on that you tell me
that three 60 round kick.
Just like dancing the dance but
harder cheese it. Yes. It's,
it's just like rhythmic gymnastics.
She just doesn't know she's on educated.
I mean if dance is an art than gymnastics
and competition is also an art because
it's very similar. It's just
under more pressure. Right.
So if gymnastics is an art,
how the fuck is how our three
60 round kicks not, oh shit.
That guy on the ground is, it was a
bad motherfucker. Hey, it's weird.
She used her lifetime achievement award
to talk shit about MMA and football.
I think she was making a
clumsy larger point. But yes.
Oh, it was Nina and saw often.
No, and he didn't start off one.
Whoa.
Rear naked around three.
That's a Amanda Nunez girlfriend.
Holla. Holla, get some,
get some red penny nights sauce,
then it's an awesome
story. Huh? Listen man,
she's a bad motherfucker,
motherfucker. Yeah, she,
I guess she has a mother Fucker fucker.
Shit motherfucker a motherfucker. She's,
she's, she's a fucking world champion
man. A legit champion. Who's your,
who's your biggest challenge do you think?
Right.
A lot of big challenges shift
Chanko is a good challenge.
It's so as Julianna Pena,
whoever wins that fight steps up and says,
well listen to Holly and uh,
whoever the fuck wins that fight
versus Holly and Germain de Randamie.
It's a very interesting fight
because if chip Chenko and we'll see,
you got shift Chanko, you've got your
main to random me and you get Holly Holm.
Those are three super advanced strikers
that could wind up facing Amanda Nunez.
Nunez can jump to 45 right now and vacate.
Yes,
she can do whatever the fuck you want to
do. Just pure chaos. Can I got an idea?
What the fuck is? Here's the dark
horse cat Zingano cuts and gone. Oh,
beat Amanda Nunez and she stopped her.
She knows she's not active,
but he's not active in the
company. She ran back. She
ramps it up. She ramps it up.
She's still in the heat. Let's get
ramped up the fuck the fuck up.
That is bad
ass. I agree. I like it. There's
a lot going on. So then Amanda,
just vacate that belt or two time champ.
Champ champ.
She comes champ champ,
female champ. Champ.
First female checks a punks headline of
fucking paper view and I don't know man.
I think Amanda has the one quality that
everybody wants to see and she has the
ability to stop women.
I mean fucking stop them.
The way she stopped Sarah the,
when she stopped me, she ah,
she smashes two lectures.
She's murked two leg.
She feels like she
seems like a s s faster.
She seems just generally more
explosive than every female by far.
She's very long. Some drawers, a
hundred pounds heavier sideboards.
So pitch cyber,
it's not,
it's two 35 she's a building with feet.
She's,
she hired the same lawyer.
John Jones in a lesbian or you
see that I'm gonna fuck is nasty.
Who was the lawyer? Whoever got
Oj off? No, no, I don't know.
They got excited. Sent the Dream
Team. Johnnie Cochran, he's dead.
I think that, you know, look, she's
obviously, she's got a real problem,
but I don't even think she really is a
one 45 or I think sidewalks at one 55 I
wouldn't say one 85 I mean that's
what she's walking around that,
but if she white now decided to
fight whatever her natural weight is,
we've been pushing this for a while.
I think that's the future.
I think the future is you show up,
you show up at people's camps randomly,
just same way you're do. When you saw the
test, you do it for fucking six months.
You'd test them. You find out what the
actually fucking way, what do you weigh?
What do you win when you train and
you never know when they're coming.
So you got to stay light and
you have to find out, oh look,
Brian Callen you one
75 that's what you way,
not one 45 one 75 that's
what you fight that.
And so you have an obligation to get to
your lowest body fat and you know that
the UFC has coming
knocking on your door with,
with weight tests to answer anyway.
Classes. Well, no one's gonna know.
No one's gonna know when this happens.
And then you sit it down and you
blow up the fucking champions.
You blow up the whole thing and you
start from scratch. 37 champion,
a world series of champions,
everyone to chase every 10 pounds,
every 10 pounds, you have the
opportunity to lose some body fat.
That's what they're doing now though.
Look at all these interim belts.
They might as well do it. No,
no, no. This is different. No,
I'm just saying everyone's
getting a belt and I was,
we'll fucking have not and belt,
this is a couple of belts thrown around.
It's just Tony Ferguson,
Tony Henderson and Kala beep.
I think a Ferguson and Henderson is
such a Ferguson and Habib is such a good
fight. Spice here so far. I don't
care. I need it five rounds.
I don't give a fuck how many
belts. Yeah. Oh he fucked up.
He fucked up Victor [inaudible].
He was doing it from a standing position.
Oh and they let her,
oh look at that.
So he went for it earlier and then Pascoe
gets on top and so he wraps his arm
around and then he lets
pesky amount to me.
Doesn't even try to stop the Mount and
he just sinks it in from the bottom
putting a karate. His hand is in a karate
chop like that. Wow. Very interesting.
First Eagle choke finish in UFC
history and he did it from the,
from being mounted hard looking man,
that is so incredible.
I feel like otherwise you just going to
keep doing the same thing over there.
How much does tire in order the way
right now? Tell you what it's not.
What 70 fuck no. What's he the every
bit of 200 and shredded. He's huge.
He's good. He's not tall but may
real quick. I'll talk with them.
Said me and him have the same haircut. I
beg to differ sir. I it doesn't matter.
It is not the same.
I that's first on the scene.
They're going over the submission.
Really fascinating.
I wonder if other people are going to
try to pull this off. Oh the pull off.
Obviously he's got it down pat.
So he gets this at some Russian shit and
the other and the other guy is fucking
punch him in the head here and he lets
them pass. They forces them to stay there.
Incredible Grapevine. His legs
from the outside. Yup. Yup. Crazy.
He's like kind of holding onto him like
trying to like create space or something.
So I wonder, it's interesting he
doesn't get his, he doesn't get this in.
He doesn't you to kind of ask what would,
if we don't have to
fuck with it after this.
Well you'd have to go like need a
belly maybe and her shirt. Yeah,
we'll need a belly if you go
need a belly from there. I see.
Say if you pass instead of mount and stay,
if you like go to one side,
you know any bravo doesn't mount anymore.
We were having this discussion about this,
I think it was on the podcast here
you're saying cause he got submitted from
this and it just does need a belly.
Well so many people are so good at that
now guys with a lot of leg dexterity and
flexibility and they throw those legs
up on the top and that but they also go
for the ankle,
lock them in there so tight with that.
Especially like you know Eddie roles a
lot of times with either g pants on or
with tights with spats and so if you got
those a rash guards on man it creates a
lot of friction. Different game. Yeah.
It's one of the reasons why a lot of the
real high level leg lock eyes you see
Gary Tonin, you see Eddie comments,
they wear shorts now, right? Yeah.
Which is really even more impressive.
They can catch those things cause that
was part of the reasons why a lot of guys
like Aoki would wear those crazy
tights was for that extra traction.
Who's dome for him too? Yeah, it
was awesome. Then we took them off.
It wasn't shit I can think of that.
He took them off, got his ass.
Once she got his ass whooped,
he had to deal with the elbows to right.
Either way it goes, got a spot somewhere.
I'm going to have to go home. See
my wife. Oh wait. Don't yet reasons.
Just trying to watch the slang,
some Dick gift amount and a
gift to my piece. Wow. Right.
Well we go honey, you just earned
this. I'm 49 we wrap this up.
It's a 10 past 10 it was a fun,
fun podcast. Stuck some fighting.
We did.
We definitely can't get the main fight
and I want you guys to keep this image in
mind. The rich guy was talking
about with getting a canister.
I big fucking like
canister and have girls,
these guys and make sure you
shit on Brian about John Joseph.
John Tweet
tweet for me. John, I'm sure you know
him. I'm sure. Goodbye. You fucks.
Okay.